there's no time o clock hello out there
and play gland time once again for
another of our regular episodes of
searching the clock podcast this is
episode 191 yeah we don't have to do too
much chitchat setting this up like we
used to because sidetrack shows keep you
guys abreast to what we're doing anyway
so although I have to say that I thought
that once we started the sidetrack show
that we wouldn't go off on as many side
tracks last time we did and we still
have been doing it anyway just because
that's how we do yeah we can't help
ourselves do we have any shout outs or
anything like that um just a couple
really brief ones we have a new $20
patron named Nico thank you very much
and welcome to the show also gonna give
another shout out to our friend Rob
Levinson from out of time pictures he
sends us movies all the time like a lot
of the movies that we have reviewed like
the past couple weeks have been sent
from him he also he just sent me a new
one he sent me a blu-ray of cat's-eye
the Stephen King anthology film it was
good from 1985 which Tom had never seen
on Ursus so we're gonna actually review
that but I think I'm gonna probably get
to I'm probably gonna do Hellraiser
first because I think Dominic sent me
that one oh good I hadn't got around to
reviewing it yet so yeah when we got to
from Sofia we haven't watched yet yeah
we really got in nice guys I know we got
like so many movies yeah well I mean you
know not just once that people send us
but we also have you know we've got a
watch there for the matinee show and all
that other crap so you know we're always
trying to like watch some and sometimes
we just feel like watching something
we've seen before
cuz we're too drunk or too tired to pay
attention to anything new we're just
like we just want to see something that
we know
like yeah some people call this you know
[ __ ] quarantine but I'm kind of
insulted by that this is just our normal
life yeah well we were going out of the
club's yeah and going out to eat
yeah work we've monetized the [ __ ]
fandom without even meaning to yeah we
monetize the pandemic well like I said
in some ways it's kind of like oh now
everybody gets to experience what it's
like to be antisocial like me all
content creators on YouTube live like
this it doesn't really seem like that
yeah and it's it's actually kind of sad
because I was watching what's one of the
Dead Mall channels I can't remember if
it was aces adventures or one of the
other ones the other day you order it
could have been brick-and-mortar there's
so we watch so many different ones I was
watching one the other day and he said
that he had three jobs like gig type
jobs like he worked like he was a door -
or uber driver or something like that
and he had like two other like jobs and
he's lost all three of them Wow
so he's really kind of I guess he's just
kind of relying on his patreon for the
You Tube channel and I don't know how
much that is because I never checked but
I was like yeah a lot of these you know
depending on what kind of job you had
you might not think is very average to
have like 500 bucks a month I think
that's about the average yeah right
that's probably about right I mean other
than a few like really big heavy hitters
that make like kind of like a ridiculous
amount like you know that about 500
bucks a month and then somebody makes a
break out and they make you know six six
grand a month
seven grand a month how much is how much
does was it beer and board games make um
it's like seven eight grand a month it
was a lot it might have been more than
that but but the thing is there are two
of them that are on the show all the
time and then they have two people like
rotating lots of yes they have lots of
guests so I don't know if they give them
something or and it looks like they have
like a lot of production costs because
like I said that's not the only show
they do know you like or if they do like
three or four other shows a week yeah
that's a hold
channel they got yeah they have like a
whole [ __ ] ton of different shows so
it's like you know it sounds like a lot
but you know yeah they do it's you know
it's an amazing amount of like editing
and [ __ ] like that cuz it's you know
they're edited like a lot nicer than
this one is cuz this is I just kind of
slapped together I'm an operator walk by
the window could barely see it might
have been a dog next door or maybe
sasquatch it's a dog that's what it is
oh it could no it's baby Squatch yeah
okay I'm walking on all fours baby sass
baby baby have you seen the commercials
for the I know this is like neither here
nor there but it just reminded me
because you said sasquatch see I told
you we're good still gonna go off on
sidetracked um have you seen the
commercials for I think it's called dr.
Squatch like soap for men legitimately
those are the only commercials that when
they come on YouTube like at the
beginning of one of the videos I will
sit and watch the whole thing even
though they're like two and a half
minutes long because they're so [ __ ]
stinky hairy dudes no it's it's it's
like they're like natural soaps it's a
line of natural soaps and shampoos and
stuff like that but just the guy like
the pitchman they have on there is so
[ __ ] funny and it's like just there's
two different commercials like I think
the first one's a little bit funnier
than the second but they're both really
really funny and it's like now I I don't
know I have to all have to show it to
you after the show just for by me [ __ ]
up because I think you'll get a kick out
of it too it is really funny but that's
legitimately the only commercial that
I'll sit there and watch with that show
about today we're talking about now this
was actually a recommendation I don't
remember who recommended it somebody
recommended like a while back now this
is really weird because this guy Samuel
little he's a serial killer and if they
if all of his confessions and stuff are
correct which the FBI has no reason to
doubt that they are then he has taken
the dubious crown of America's most
prolific serial killer taking it away
from Gary Ridgway who was convicted of
49 murders you'll remember we did a show
about him a while back this guy they
think has killed 93 women and we're not
talking about artists and all what's his
name no level [ __ ]
right now it was his name artists and
Henry Lee we can't really Lucas yeah
yeah no yeah full of [ __ ] that yeah they
they maybe killed two or three people
yeah this guy they're pretty sure that
he killed all the people that he said he
killed because I mean and this it's over
like several decades he started killing
people in nineteen seventy I believe or
71 and yeah they think 93 people now
they've confirmed
I believe 50 or 60 the FBI has just
because he knows so many details about
it and they have like a case that
matches up with that our body that
matches up with that the other ones
they're still trying to like identify
the other murders because he seems to
remember like a lot of [ __ ] about them
too he's in prison now like he's been
convicted of eight but they think that
he did a [ __ ] ton more and the weird
thing about it is that you know he just
got caught in 2012 and for many years
like after he was put in prison like for
initially they put him in there for
three murders in LA and one in Texas so
it was for initially and for the first
few years he was in prison he pretty
much said no I didn't do any of that
[ __ ] I don't know any of these women
stuff like that but then when 2018
rolled around I guess because he was
getting old and he was like in bad
health and everything like that he's
still alive
but I guess he decided that he was just
gonna like give everything up because he
started talking and that's when they
found out that that maybe there's like a
lot of cold cases out there cuz we're
talking like several states like 14
states or something like that cuz he
used to just like wander around he's
like transient what's weird is that some
of these guys claimed to have killed all
these people and then they'll say that
they forgot about certain murders
that's a [ __ ] weird concept in it you
could it's very weird
as you could forget one of them yeah I
mean I could see if you've killed 93
people I can see one or two of them slip
in your mind I would think a lot of them
probably slip your mind because it
becomes commonplace and there's so many
of them to the
Maurice might get jumbled together over
time yeah and I think that this guy I
mean listening to him talk he seems to
have a fairly good memory of stuff like
sometimes he confuses like he can't
remember exactly what year it was he's
like oh it was 74 or 75 somewhere around
there but he usually remembers what city
it was he remembers what car he was
driving he remembers the woman's first
name he didn't usually know their last
names because a lot of them were sex
workers or you know just women he met in
bars and he remembers what they look
like so much so that he is able to do
these very creepy looking but scarily
accurate drawings of them it's got a
pretty good memory yeah that's weird
because like guys that have killed a
bunch of people in normal circumstances
and I'm saying normally be like combat
yeah I mean like it they'll recall it
and they'll remember quite a bit about
it yeah you know what I mean
after all those years and I'm just I'm
just saying it is this kind of weird
that there can be so many of them and
they're it's a it's a personal event
between you and some chick you've killed
her and you can't clearly remember it
that's just [ __ ] bizarre when like
you know I've heard interviews of guys
you know German guys just [ __ ] mowing
down American soldiers trying to come
out of the damn landing crafts a d-day
you know and he's accurately saying yeah
you know I laid down a [ __ ] fire
right into that thing as soon as the
soon as the gates opened up I [ __ ]
just chewed him up must have killed
about 40 of them you know and he can
remember it pretty clearly yeah guys
trying to jump over the sides it's like
a big event in his life not necessarily
negative either you know he's defending
his buddies and his unit and his country
you know you know far as he's concerned
and then you know it's you know hearing
guys who were out in Japan on that
island fight and you know one guy was a
flame thrower man and he talked about
getting up close to a pillbox and
squirting all that down burning gasoline
in that pillbox full of Japanese the
heat he described it as curling him up
like bacon glass some [ __ ] [ __ ]
he said I've just curled him up
like bacon that's yeah yeah is so and it
was an old dude took it to his trip but
at least he had a memory of it yeah you
know I mean it's just shocking to me
that it did could murder a woman on a
personal level up close like that with
with the hands by hands or knives or
something like that and not remember it
and this guy some of them like I said
this guy is actually probably um I don't
I don't know if I'd say an exception but
because he does seem to remember he
could member what they looked uh what
they looked like and he remembers
sometimes he remembers their first name
see remembers what they were wearing
what car he was driving what the
circumstances were
yeah then cat scratching around back
here she's just gonna do that don't do
it
um you know he he remembers all that and
but you have to think like some of these
women he was hanging out with them like
for a couple of days before he had a
personal connection was yeah before he's
like he would pick him up in a bar they
were like you know a lot of them were
sex workers or drug addicts or something
like that so he would like kind of blow
into town go to some seedy club and like
pick someone up and then she would ask
for a ride somewhere or something like
that
yeah and then he would just decide he
was gonna kill her okay it's just it's
really creepy there's okay so since he
that's why his memory is so good because
he actually spent time with a bet time
with them some of the other guys that I
remember that forgot about it they were
just like random woman he didn't know
her very long they just like grabbed
your ass yeah it wasn't or some poker he
picked up he only you know what that
didn't take very long yeah and he was
you know 20 minutes later he was
strangling her you know so yeah it might
be that as he knew him maybe he could
remember him better but alright cuz I'm
thinking 90 you know that's a lot yeah
between 1993 people going all the way
going way back to the early 70s yeah
yeah so and I I think I said 14 states
before it's actually nineteen states
across the nineteen states so as you can
imagine once this guy started talking in
2018 and because he only started talking
in 2018 there isn't a [ __ ] ton of
information I mean there's a lot of like
snippets of like various news stories
there's some snippets of interviews with
him like on YouTube there's really no
because you know how you sue me you're
like bigger-ticket serial killers if you
want to call them that like they'll have
like a few hour long like documentaries
about them like a biography
like a true-crime documentary or
something he doesn't really have that
there's a couple of them you know that
other like youtubers have done that are
just like 10 15 20 minutes long he
doesn't even have a dis blew my mind he
doesn't even have a murder pedia entry
hmm and he's killed 93 people he'll be
yeah so it's just like I guess because
this is still a developing story and you
know I'm gonna try and kind of cover all
the basics and stuff but to be honest
you know once he started confessing and
you know the FBI got involved and
everything like that then every state
that he's been in like all of the
authorities from those states have been
coming to talk to him to see if they can
clear some of their cold cases or match
them up with ones that he's confessed to
that they haven't matched up yet so what
I'll do is I'll kind of just go into
like a little bit of like of him in his
history and stuff like that and then I'm
gonna go into on the FBI's website there
are five cases in particular that they
are trying to get to the bottom of
because most of the other ones they've
kind of matched up to actual cases but
there are five that he has confessed to
and they haven't matched it up to a case
yet perhaps because the body has not
been found because he does remember
where he dumped some of the bodies and
some of it does seem like a place where
you wouldn't find it you know what I
mean and because it was such a long time
ago or you know there might have been
some wires crossed somewhere with like
an unidentified body or whatever but
those are kind of the five that they're
working on at the time that you know at
the moment or at least like the last I
checked which I think was like 2019
sometime so yeah um like I said he's
he'd beat Gary Ridgway wonder if Gary
were chose man
I don't think where they found it Gary
Ridgway is kind of a beta he probably
doesn't he wasn't in a Probab wasn't
even aware of it maybe like he beat my
record yeah I don't think Gary which way
you know which way we'd wait Gary I
think was the kind of guy that was all
what uh-huh oh I didn't do no I didn't
do nothing he's like one of those yeah
uh-huh
I didn't kill her but uh uh uh
I'm innocent well yeah also I wanted to
mention to you like another another kind
of big-time serial killer is Harold
Shipman yeah Hughes the English yeah uh
he was a doctor yeah he killed do you
want 250 people no but yeah but it was
mostly like um patients of his yes it's
easier to do yeah and I do feel like he
he doesn't get brought up a lot with
like a lot of the kids a lot of his
crimes weren't real splashy like he just
kind of did it like for insurance money
and stuff like that so he was just like
robbing people actually was a doctor
I was even like listening to [ __ ] or
I was reading that interview with the
last podcast and the left guys and they
were like we were gonna do a show on
Harold Shipman but you know because he
killed 250 [ __ ] people but it's like
he just kind of did it for money which
it doesn't make like a real exciting it
wasn't I can't even remember at the main
hundreds no I don't think it was that
long ago I think it was fairly recent
all right but um yeah I mean I might we
might do a show about him one of these
days too because I'm sure there's like
enough interesting to talk about right
now much to talk about kind of like
those angel of death nurses and then and
I was thinking about this to them yeah I
was thinking about that the other day
like when I was you know out walking and
I was thinking about this show and I was
thinking about serial killers and even
though you know your Angel of Death type
killers or someone like Harold Shipman
or somebody like that would still be
considered a serial killer in the sense
that they you know killed more than two
or three people like in you know other
incidents and stuff sorry dogs barking
necks or you know what I mean it just
doesn't seem like even though they're
technically a serial killer I feel like
they're not serial killers in spirit if
that's not too [ __ ] up to say just
because they don't seem to have the same
motivation it's a more like a multiple
murderer or a mass murderer yeah because
I feel like even somebody like say Belle
Gunness or somebody like that who was
just killing people just for practical
reasons which a lot of female serial
killers do just because they were trying
to get insurance money or they're trying
to you know various other things that's
generally what they are doing so they're
not really doing it for any kind of
sexual yeah I think
pleasure at one time the FBI last I had
heard the FBI's said that it had they
had to have a sexual motive to it
that that's really what makes you what
they considered to be a sexual well that
type of sexual or serial killer yeah
that's how zero killer is this is
basically it has greater sexual must
wait yes the other ones are things like
spree killers mass murderers and
multiple murderers yeah not the same
thing as what they are calling a serial
killer yeah it has to have some kind of
like psychosexual commit it's a rapist
it's a serial rapist he happens to kill
the victim
yeah and he gets into that and it does
seem like Samuel little had that no
Samuel little um he's kind of
interesting out he's he's a black man
not many black serial killers other than
we did a show about the Grim Sleeper yes
statistically now is likely
statistically not very likely um but
there may be a genetic component who
knows
yes might might have a certain kind of
genetic genetic structure that makes
them gravitate towards serial killing
yeah it could be because it does seem
like there's many there's a lot fewer
black serial killers there's fewer Asian
ones yeah okay and you know think
Chinese people are the most common
people in the world they don't have a
big problem serial killing now it could
be this type of society that there is
yeah it could be a cultural to cultural
thing you know I mean they don't have
privacy here that type of deal everybody
you know there's too much security or
whatever there's no dating scene that
type of deal yeah there's not quite the
same and you know they do have they do
kind of have underground prostitution
there but it's kind of I guess it's I
guess in something for some reason it's
safer yeah
maybe you'd that too but it could be
though it could be that there's
something with white guys I'm saying
this as a white guy it could be
something in white guys in the in their
upbringing to where it's more likely
that they become a serial killer not to
say that white guys are serial killers
it's just that when there are serial
killers is more likely to be it's gonna
be a way almost always a way yeah I mean
I don't know what the percentage is but
it's got it's upwards of eighty five
percent I would think an explanation I
heard
is that one is sexual deviance and
sexual deviance is in blacks and in
Orientals and everything is just that in
the United States and in the West sexual
deviance with a white guy the white guy
has a slight advantage because he can
move freely amongst society without
being noticed
Cherno he always looks he doesn't look
like he's out of place unless he goes to
the hood he looks like he's out of place
but so it has kind of a freedom of
movement that you need to be a serial
killer that is actually a very good
point I wonder if that I bet has got to
be a factor I would think cuz if you're
black and yours and you're walking
around like in a totally white
neighborhood everybody's gonna call ups
on use but so it means you have the
jury'll that means you have to do it in
the black neighborhood right well
chances are you get killed in a black
neighborhood doing that [ __ ] yes I'm
just gonna shoot your face Yeah right
yeah so you know it's a rougher
neighborhood they got better survival
skills there you know that's not a knock
you know but they got good they got good
awareness in black neighborhoods because
you gotta watch your back yeah you have
to so you know they're not they're not
the sitting ducks that white people
white women are I guess you could say
although yes so um most of Samuel
littles victims were black women the
majority of them but he did kill white
women and Hispanic women as well he even
said like in one of his interviews and
his interviews are like so creepy
because he's like he's old now I mean
he's like 78 79 something like that and
he seems so if you didn't know that he
was a serial killer you would have no
[ __ ] way just comes off as like so
like friendly avuncular it was a serial
killer because he didn't get caught he
did one of the reasons why he didn't get
caught is because the victims didn't
suspect him yeah he just so he just
seemed super friendly so I guess it was
just very easy for him to I mean I don't
know what he was like when he was
younger because I mean the thing about
Samuel little is that he was in prison I
mean he got arrested all the time just
not usually for murder
he got usually he was arrested for
things like kidnapping or sexual
assaults or armed robbery or pretty much
any crime you can think of he fought
and in it somewhere and he would be put
in jail but he would be put in jail for
like little [ __ ] sentences or he
would get he was arrested for murder a
couple times but like got off with it
because it was like not enough evidence
and all this other kind of [ __ ] so even
though I think he went to jail like over
one like ten year he only went was spent
like ten years in jail like over this
whole entire time even though he was
killing people this whole entire time
just for other little smaller so yes
he's black most of the victims are black
most of them what was his reputation
like in the community there was he kind
of a trusted guy or they just thought
the harmless guy that's the thing though
he didn't stay in one community he was
like he moved around all over the point
what his mannerisms were like did he
have like a charisma to where he seemed
like he was cool so it prom I think so
he seemed like he would even though like
you know I don't know what he was like
when he was younger but I mean like I
said he was a criminal um you know and
he got arrested for various other things
for robbery and [ __ ] like that but it
doesn't seem like people well some
chicks are into that well and the thing
too is that most of the women that he
killed were sex workers yeah so this day
was just like you know they were just
like yeah he would pick him up in a bar
in the crowd deadness yes so it didn't
seem all that weird and like I said he
didn't spend a lot of time in any
particular City so it wasn't like he got
he was established in a community and he
was killing all these people and nobody
knew about it because like Grim Sleeper
was kind of like that he was kind of
like lived in this one community and
nobody had any idea that he was a
[ __ ] serial this helped his hunting
strategy because he was in and he was
out yeah he was just like moving around
all the time he was he like Bundy right
so yeah things are you know you didn't
make a disturbance when he went in his
everybody seemed he's like he was
alright he might kill a couple people
and then he'd slip that guy that's
exactly do really weren't even sure who
that dude was and they forgot about him
you didn't stick out and because oh and
sadly because most of the victims were
sex workers not all of them yeah um
no suspects no suspects yeah and the
cops really I mean I hate to say it but
the cops really didn't seem to care all
that much well how can you find a
suspect she's a she if she's getting 20
30 clients a day again anyone could have
been anyone so you just there's no
suspects and some of the bodies have
never been
right so you know there's that so Samuel
little he was born in 1940 in Reynolds
Georgia yeah now he said later on that
his mom was a prostitute which I don't
have any reason to disbelieve that now
some sources say that he was actually
born while she was in jail I don't know
if that's true or not cuz I've heard
that she was just a prostitute and he
was born at her or that he was born in
jail I don't really know so the victim
profiles the same profiles his mom yeah
there you go
so psychologist so if I could try to
tell you a story behind that that might
might mean something or might not mean
something you know yeah lashing out at
the mom at the birthday always yeah
sometimes it seems it seems like a lot
of serial killers have that kind of
pathology where they're you have there
it's like they're almost like punishing
their mom yeah it's just something about
the way certain guys might react to a
situation like that if the mom was cruel
and then I think it's more to it than
that
yeah it's not that the mom's a hooker
the moms that might be a hooker and
she's an [ __ ] that's because yes a
lot of guys that had their moms were a
hooker from the hood you know I mean
Richard Pryor's moms over yeah if I
remember correctly he at least grew up
in a brothel yeah
but I think I think he said his mom and
most of them kids turned out okay he's
alright
he thought he thought the [ __ ] was funny
I guess he thought it was sad but he
didn't yeah he wanted to [ __ ] get
involved in entertainment get the hell
out of that situation they did yeah Oh
Pryor people forgot all about Richard
Pryor he's a great entertainer any good
man he certainly set himself on fire
though but he you know yeah it happens
yeah you got EMS or something didn't
something like that yeah wouldn't it
multiple sclerosis her wheelchair yeah I
can't remember yeah [ __ ] that was a wild
man he had some good movies we need to
see some [ __ ] Richard Pryor and not
really see it gene Wilder like Silver
Streak mr. crazy and stir crazy yeah
that was a long time that was like
peanut butter and jelly those two that
was like so real it's too [ __ ]
opposites they were [ __ ] hilarious if
any of you youngsters have never seen
Richard Pryor gene Wilder working
together go check that [ __ ] they made a
bunch of movies say that and as far as
far as I can remember those movies those
move there the humor would have aged
pretty well I haven't seen them I mean
we'll see I haven't seen em D I was a
kid either
Araya probably aged pretty well but I
remember them being really funny
I've actually been pretty kis remember
how I said like a lot of the comedies
that I really liked when I was a kid
like Ghostbusters and stuff like that
and then I saw it again when I was older
I was like and I was thank God that it's
still funny yeah oh yeah Ghostbusters is
still good yeah Ghostbusters is still
hilarious so it was a man with two
brains I was very very happy because I
used to love that movie when I was like
a teenager and I was like man I'll be so
sad if I watch that it's not funny
anymore history of the world open still
history of the world did not age well
Eddie Murphy stand-up routines did not
age well well like I said that's because
it's not anymore back in the day it was
everything I wanted to age well super
well yeah that was that was still good
yeah really good um and what age really
well is even better when it first came
out was the golden child I thought that
I loved that when I was younger and I
didn't like it but I still liked it but
I don't like it quite as much it's a
cheap movie when we saw it recently we
didn't see a good we saw a DVD print and
it was [ __ ] I bet you if we saw a
totally restored version and feel a bit
better but it was a fun movie but you
know I liked Howard the Duck so yeah I'm
an American being I dance come back with
[ __ ] dolomite man it was a good movie
I know there was like it was Oscar buzz
about it but he didn't get nominated I
think he got nominated for some things
but you guys haven't seen Dola Dola
might is my name on Netflix go check
that [ __ ] out that [ __ ] I gotta watch on
one of the matinee shows that was a good
show yeah so I'm not really sure if he
was actually born in jail and she was in
jail or whatever um some sources also
saying that the mom dumped him on the
side of the road but that doesn't sound
right to me because I think what ended
up happening was that she had him and
then she didn't I mean she was a single
mother obviously I don't think she knew
who the father was so she actually ended
up moving to
Lorain Ohio which is where her mother
lived and you know so she would have
like a support network to help her like
raise the kid and then I think she moved
back to Florida so he was actually
raised by his grandmother in Lorraine Oh
Ohio and his mom went back to Florida so
he went to junior high I don't know if
he went to high school um he doesn't
seem like unintelligent or anything he
just didn't really apply himself he
seemed like one of those kids that was
just gonna like trouble from the get-go
you know what I mean like just getting
in trouble all the time
not really like applying himself and
[ __ ] and I believe he dropped out I
don't know if he dropped out in junior
high or high school but he did drop out
of skiing good since he dropped out of
high school if you were in hood because
the hoods version of the high school is
just [ __ ] prison
yeah it's like you're really not going
to learn anything yeah it's like prison
you know depending on what state you
know if you're around New Orleans it
just depends on where it is yeah but you
know I had friends that [ __ ] went to
high school in this rather Ninth Ward
area and everything Louisiana that man
food stories they told me yeah I've
heard that [ __ ] was like four isn't yeah
but yeah so I'm like I said they don't
know a great deal about his childhood
and stuff like that cuz he was kind of
you know transient either transient type
of family his first conviction for a
crime occurred in 1956 when he was 16
years old that was breaking and entering
and that happened in Omaha Nebraska so
I'm guessing he started like wandering
around like early on in his life because
his grandmother lived in Ohio so he got
put in juvie
in 1956 now he was in there for a little
while um not much is known of him like
in his late teens or early twenties they
do know that when he was in his late 20s
he actually moved to Florida and moved
back in with his mother now he did
actually have a few jobs around this
time period um I heard he was like a
sanitation engineer worked for
sanitation department in Dade County or
Dodd I'm from here I'm from you know
it's Dade I'm from everywhere you know
they call dad dad but like I said in
English when you put an e at the end of
something it makes the vowel long in
Mississippi usually in Mississippi we
speak English
it's a [ __ ] high-tech aristocratic
English that came from the 1700s but
it's more English than British English
they [ __ ] moved on we [ __ ] is still
call to [ __ ] the way you used to say
meat and hate and stuff like that
hainted I say yeah okay holler yeah my
dad my dad you say winter yeah wash the
winters no you don't say another thing
grando so yeah so he worked as a
sanitation engineer he worked in a
cemetery so you know practicing I guess
said he also worked as an ambulance
attendant I'm not really sure what that
is like that's not an EMT what is that
what does it call the ambulance
attendant
nobody's it just like everybody tries
something that works it works off of an
ambulance but not an EMT they're not the
EMT may be there some type so he'll
crash doors and helps to get the damn
try the gurney inside the foot I guess
so yeah I mean being an EMT that takes
like well I like the assistant to the
EMT yeah I guess probably what they're
talking about so apparently um even
though he had a couple jobs in Florida
where he lived his mother like like I
said at this point he's in his late 20s
um he had a bit at the wanderlust and he
didn't want to stay in one place so over
the next few years
he just started wandering around the
country he would just kind of go what he
would do generally is he would go to a
new state or a new city or whatever
steal a bunch of [ __ ] and then sell it
and either trade it for drugs he'd get
some drugs and then he would like get a
motel room and stay there for a little
while so he just basically made money
from crime you know I mean like other
than a couple like legit jobs he had in
Florida I don't think he ever had legit
jobs like after that yeah he was just
like on the grift like all the time yeah
so over the next few years he was
arrested in eight different states for
various crimes fraud shoplifting armed
robbery solicitation driving under the
influence
aggravated assault and rape so this is
back when you could get an armed robbery
charge and then continue on and do some
and then everybody just said oh well
give him like two months it almost
seemed like and I was watching like some
other a little like short documentary
about this it almost seemed like people
didn't like the authorities didn't
really want to deal with him yeah like
they were just kind of like whoa throw
them in the hole for like two months and
then just like get him the [ __ ] out of
here cuz we don't want to like look at
his face anymore yeah it definitely did
seem like they were just trying to like
move him along on his way because they
felt like armed robbery give you 10 to
15 years
right yeah it's like that's what I'm
thinking Rafe and he rape I could get
you 20 yeah you could get late for that
[ __ ]
I mean depending on like how great what
was where it was and what aggravates of
all or strong-arm there's different ways
yeah yeah they can get you on that but
yeah you dish it now you do serious
[ __ ] time but this is we're talking
about 70s
this is yeah that's the 67 this is
before you see now I think United States
has one of the largest prison
populations on the [ __ ] planet indeed
it does yeah we have a prison industries
here they'll just enslave you and
working in them down industries they're
basically kind of like Soviet gulags so
they're trying to get people in there
yeah don't put you in there for like
nothing yeah and then they'll get
federal funding to house you and they'll
make money off of that so that's what
[ __ ] kills me about this it's like
then they're like ask too much money
lock these guys up here good thing
though it's like in some ways this might
be a weird thing to say but it's like
back in back in those days it almost
seems like it's better to have that type
of kind of laissez-faire attitude about
like minor crimes
yeah but then this guy seemed to have
done like major [ __ ] and they just kind
of let him escape yeah I mean I hear
about crimes happening Europe my [ __ ]
jaw just drops you know like dudes he'll
just if I can
you know steal a car and get caught and
nothing happens to them you know here in
the south that's uh I think it's called
[ __ ] grand theft grand theft auto
yeah do that you're gonna get five years
you get five no to me five years seems a
little excessive just for stealing a car
no because it's an industry here yes
stealing cars they steal the cars taken
to chop shops yeah I know hoards so what
you do is you uh you just give everybody
five ten years or whatever and then for
each each offense it goes up because
you're trying to interdict the interdict
car thieving rings yeah you know to me
it seems weird that like this guy just
you know blithely kind of like skipped
across the country doing all this [ __ ]
and murdering people which they didn't
know about til later on and no one put
him in jail for anything which you know
or he'd do like a year 18 months here
and there for [ __ ] and it that just
seems like [ __ ] crazy to me now like
I said I am of this like if you
committed a crime where it didn't like
hurt anybody or just like a property
crime like I said like stealing a car or
like you know just stealing [ __ ] from a
store or whatever it's like yeah you
should be punished for that but I don't
think they should give you [ __ ] five
years or as that's ridiculous
yeah um you know but then on the other
hand if you do violent [ __ ] then yeah
they should lock your ass up but that
did not happen with this individual and
that's it to many people's detriment
guess you could say the way the United
States that was back dance kind of like
kind of like the way Europe is now I
mean you know there are guys in Europe
raping ten-year-old girls and getting
like only a couple months for it you
repetition you rape a ten-year-old girl
here you're gonna do 30 years well and
you get raped in prison if they find out
well and then if you ever get out you'll
still be on the sexual offender yes
however forever yeah like that'll always
be yeah which I'm not sure I don't know
this might be and I don't know if I
mentioned this before that might this
might be a controversial statement but I
feel like the sexual offender list like
I don't know we need that because I do
want to know like if some dude that like
is
[ __ ] on parole for some of that [ __ ]
is like living next door or whatever
that's good information to have but if
somebody that committed a crime like
that and did say 30 years like you say
and then they let him out I don't think
they should leave mama because he's
never gonna be able to reintegrate into
society it wasn't love it I think I
don't know this it's like a really hard
that's like a really hard thing to like
[ __ ] sort out you know there was a
lot of [ __ ] that got instituted you know
a lot of it got instituted back in the
70s that's kana when you think about it
pretty [ __ ] mean-spirited I'm not
sure I totally agree with the whole
concept functional concept of felon it
just it's kind of stupid
if a guy has done his [ __ ] time and
paid for his crime then he should be
able to come out and be a citizen again
yeah because they have guns with it it
doesn't help like like he did for his
crime don't let him out don't let him
enter that's what I'm saying like if you
and I and I'm not like advocate like if
people did something really [ __ ] up
like just leave him in there and throw
the key away yeah but if you think that
they've been rehabilitated commit they
didn't like do a crime that was like
super violent they don't seem likely to
reoffending if you decide that if a
bunch of people decide that it's okay to
let them out then let them out like wipe
the [ __ ] because he's gonna go try and
get a job no one's gonna give him a job
it's like the you know what I mean what
were they did with the sex offenders is
that they were sidwell all sex offenders
are serial sex offenders so we have to
[ __ ] keep an eye on them so you want
to know where they all are but then they
may pass laws where you can't live in
this county so yeah then you end up with
homeless camp yeah it's like we're gonna
lose a camp it's like I know nobody
wants them to live like next-door to
them it's like yeah I don't either but
it's like they have to live someplace if
they're gonna let them out don't let
them out it's kind of like the American
war on drugs it's not well thought out
it was something that they passed
without really thinking about the
implication well it's that's the thing
is [ __ ] these people would get high I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
well like I said that really does seem
like that like minor drug offenses that
really seems like something that
shouldn't even be I mean it's from now
there may be a little bit fine
something like that I'm really over date
about it I like in the olden days in the
1800s and the night their half first
half of the [ __ ] 1900s you had a
right to what you did with your own body
if women can have abortions and do this
and that then if they can take birth
control pills then why can't you get
high that's what that's why I don't
really have a problem as long as they
keep you from bull just like now it's
like I you know people can drink alcohol
as long as you don't drive around and if
you kill somebody you're gonna answer
for that yeah you know what I mean and
they have no thing at you driving around
like when you're drunk that's fine if
you put it all all that [ __ ] that's what
I mean if you just want to sit in your
house and do drugs and not go anyplace I
don't give a [ __ ] about that
do whatever you want you know what I
mean yeah it's you know what I mean but
so it's it's just weird because I mean
that's the thing I think people tend to
think of like you know authorities or
like governments to show like this big
like monolithic kind of thing but it's
not it's just like bunch of randoms it's
a bunch of no it's like well it's a
bunch of random people and a bunch of a
bunch of random times you know different
places different circumstances and all
just kind of like cobbled together like
in the best way that they could think of
at the time yeah it was funny as
civilizations go through something
called senility is that they have these
laws and the laws are too very hard to
change but time moves on and now some of
the laws don't match the situation
anymore that anybody match the culture
so you know the laws have to change with
the times and you know a lot of these
weird laws were made for generations
that no longer exist like there are
county laws out of Mississippi they say
that you cannot it's illegal to wash
laundry on Sunday is a [ __ ] of your what
I mean it's like not on a Sunday the
both situation I loved it
I love this sometimes like look at some
of this just like really weird like
arcane laws like Hansel like no eating
ice cream in the street yeah this hour
in this hour and I'm like what what
possible circumstantial Kabat Johnny
Jones County has single-handedly bad
porn in Jones County some Alabama
someplace
an Alabama can't sell sex toy can you
great they all have internet yes I guess
there's no possibility they pay in porn
they got international way to enforce
that yeah so and then they're like you
can't have sex toys they got eBay they
got all kinds of [ __ ] you could order
that [ __ ] up line yeah are online so the
laws don't [ __ ] make sense that was
those are laws that were made during the
1800s in their nineteen hundreds and as
a southern baptists that really just
voted to impress the church congregation
and then they turn turn right around
broke those laws it well in the dumb
things laws really don't mean anything
it means the thing about it it's like
County to County it's like you know some
like for example like when I was growing
up
you know you weren't allowed to buy
certain types of fireworks in the county
where I grew up but you could drive
right to the next county and get
anything you want bring it back and then
if you got caught you could just say oh
well I'm like a blasted and do well or
some good and the cops are just like
okay cool it's funny you know cuz I'd go
up to places live in places like
Michigan and living in Boston they took
laws seriously I mean they were like it
was for real yeah Mississippi laws
aren't real
that's just what you know that's just me
it's like you know it obviously we do
need laws but I think that a lot of laws
were passed a long time ago and the
situations that they applied to no
longer apply Mississippi Mississippi
would pass a law that was totally
ridiculous and they would pass that law
because that's what the preachers told
him to pass that day in church and it
was to make everything look good it was
like face face-saving yeah I know saving
faith is like that and then right after
its passed they go right out and break
that law like it never even [ __ ] hat
yeah of course it's just salt it's just
a show yeah no that [ __ ] was for real
now of course you didn't run around
killing everybody you know and [ __ ]
they're actually very moral people you
know in terms of like well I guess you
say they're not stealing a killing or
anything like that but other than that
they just do the [ __ ] they want to do I
mean you know we used to [ __ ] use
[ __ ] black powder and [ __ ] blow
anvils [ __ ] 200 feet in the air and
we'll shoot I don't think I've told that
story making cannons and stuff and that
was a Super Bowl
oh damn cannon boy it damn a boom try to
get there's some YouTube videos of it
I'm saying yeah yeah and cops it [ __ ]
go down and run around they're
good-looking they go you know who shot
that anvil no evil his Super Bowl Super
Bowl da yeah well it's just kind of like
like I said it was just kind of like 4th
of July we had all kind of illegal
fireworks oh yeah they were illegal in
our County but not in the next County
you know and like I said you would shoot
the [ __ ] [ __ ] off in your backyard
maybe a cop would stop and be like hey
you know turn that down a little bit
you'd be like yeah but he was just kind
of like just wait till I'm gone you can
fine yeah it was all concepts just don't
hurt any money we do all kinds of well
your fingers on Mississippi I can't talk
about
I'm sure the statute is yeah I mean
somebody had to be federal problem yeah
you know what it's a guy like some some
fed somebody from the FBI might be
randomly watching this show on their
lunch break and maybe like they're gonna
come get you can I come like tomorrow
somebody will be like knocking on the
door Thomas Ross but yeah so we said all
that to say that nowadays like you kind
of get put in jail for like [ __ ]
stuff but apparently back in the 60s and
70s you go around a rape and kill and
armed robbery not like that and you
would just get thrown in jail for like a
little while they beat ya [ __ ] off just
don't do it again okay yeah she's just a
hooker yeah that really does seem like a
lot of it and I'm I hate to say I am
raper I just didn't want to pay her
that was probably defense right yeah it
was rape and yeah and that's the sad
thing and I'm we've talked about like
other cases to where a lot of the
victims were you know sex workers and
stuff like even the Long Island serial
killer where a lot of more like
Craigslist escorts and stuff and it
really does seem like I hate to say it
uh you know I don't want to [ __ ] on the
cops too much but it does seem like if
the victims are sex workers they kind of
seem to like not prioritize it as much
so I can't believe them that's probably
one of the things that yeah that might
be a problem as well
don't there you know I mean or you
didn't pay what you agreed to pay her
she could turn around say that you raped
her and the cops are probably all right
well you did if you didn't pay her well
the thing is though is the cops are not
going to look at it that way they're
gonna be like how many times you pull
this scam a month using you said this
last month yeah I mean so they're
probably you they probably know who she
is but the shitty thing is that like
shitty dudes will use that against her
yeah and just being a [ __ ] and
the cops tell her man watch you [ __ ]
kick that habit you walk away from the
needle so you don't have to sell it so
you don't have to put on that red light
you don't have to sell your body to the
knife you know what I love the police
but it's like I can't hear Roxanne
without hearing like Eddie Murphy
singing yeah is that ever said that is
like it's like completely like indelibly
linked in my mind was funny I love the
police though yeah so basically so he
does like some short stints in and out
of prison and Samuel little does
according to him he's actually like a
fairly big dude he was six foot three
and when he was in and out of prison he
kind of took up boxing so the this is
kind of scary but some of his victims
later on they found that one thing that
he liked to do was he would punch his
victims into unconsciousness before he
like strangled them and [ __ ] one of the
victims I can't remember which one it
was because a lot of them were like
unidentified or they don't know their
names at this point one of them he
punched her in the abdomen so hard that
it broke her spine damn I don't believe
it I don't believe the man could punch
somebody hard enough to break this I
don't know like I said in the front or
he's a big dude I'm not really sure I
don't know if it was the must've hit her
on it back but still that so that's
still [ __ ] out whether it was from the
front of the back yeah so yeah so like I
said so he got three years in prison in
1961 that was for breaking into a
furniture store in Lorain Ohio where his
grandmother lived
so he was released from there in 1964
now by 1975 he had been arrested 26
times in 11 states attempted rape
assault theft fraud and according to
Wikipedia attacks on government
officials yeah I don't know what that
means
maybe maybe post office people
delivering mail stealing packages maybe
well like the mailbox the mailman comes
to your door like deliver a package you
just like punch him insane him yeah
following a pit puncher to steal the
packages from him I don't know
government official who would that be
IRS no that's what I mean I thought
that's what I couldn't think of it's
like cousin go to the post often people
right yeah because if it was the police
then they would have said the police
yeah like you sacking a police on that
police would have [ __ ] shot what a
shot you because yeah you know you know
I can think of is something like a
mailman maybe going up to a mail truck
beating a dudes ass and just taking all
the packages out like looking for checks
yeah of all the packages out of a mail
truck because he was like that's how he
made his living was like by stealing
[ __ ] probably he's doing robbing mail
trucks maybe he was like I said there's
not like a huge amount of information
about this guy even though he is
probably the most prolific serial kin
terms of like victim account yeah in the
United States so 1982 Samuel little gets
a risk gets arrested in Pascagoula
Mississippi and orders I hope I'm
pronouncing that right I pronounce it
right right yeah Pascagoula yeah
Pascagoula see I know how to pronounce
things yeah Pascagoula I can pronunciate
things correctly okay good now outta by
mr. Dodd County good miami-dade I can't
every day all right
it's Dave I was too highfalutin and [ __ ]
to do pants telling you it's day day
it's named after a person made just like
what [ __ ] dog hey da mo beer yeah dad
it's roll off my tongue I could see that
she was some skull and you live spit you
spit and say dad please don't do that
yeah oh my god I'm so angry that's like
so that's what [ __ ] that carnies do man
they [ __ ] dip I know you did okay
that's [ __ ] it at night so don't you
[ __ ] start that [ __ ] again I have a
little [ __ ] lies when I was a smoker
that like the [ __ ] spit can over
there it's like [ __ ] I'll be vomiting
for a big smoke at night when you're in
the Army in the field so say you had
that I had to [ __ ] put some Scholl in
there but you get used to it it's pretty
good I don't think I used to smoke too
but it's like I I'm not going that far
yeah let's go I like to focus go long
cut brown brown can and then a friend of
mine trying to get me in a snuff that's
where you have a little can i yeah no
you snorted new backhoe dust well I
never really could get that though I
didn't even it was like suddenly I
didn't even know they did snuff anymore
that was yet I feel like that was trying
to take a little angle that was like
some 1800 yeah he was trying to go even
older school he was like he was trying
to impress people just like skulls like
a hipster bro back with four [ __ ] skull
I'm going back to Napoleonic era we're
gonna do some [ __ ] snuff you're right
like that you just start coughing I was
like snoring black pepper like I was a
[ __ ] well that's kind of like sometimes
when I'm sprinkle and cinnamon in my
coffee and some of it like if you
breathe real hard and it goes up your
nose and you're like it's like green
powder like green tea you know like this
stuff yeah and you that you make for
with matcha like Mars it was like that
PMON a little bitty can about the size
of a dime yeah that's like this little
little tiny can yeah I first heard it
you know you wanna hear it's funny the
first time I heard of snuff was from I
think it was from like a Bugs Bunny
cartoon yeah that's how I get back in
the old day yeah but it's like back in
the old days like he there was like a
Bugs Bunny cartoon and I'd please
forgive me if I'm remembering this wrong
but I'm pretty sure there was a Bugs
Bunny cartoon where he met Napoleon yeah
and of course the boy was like this
little bitty Norris no yeah yeah and he
had like a yeah right yeah you know how
it started
what well the people that were in the
tobacco industry the people that shipped
it and and and moved it around you know
to bike by cart okay at the bottom of
the cart all the dust from it would fall
like hey we can sell that [ __ ] to idiot
no what happened and unloaded the clouds
of it they did they did hail it and they
got addicted to the damn dust so then
they started the dust and then they were
selling the dust and then they started
to make dust and it's tobacco dust
that's well that's you can get it back
to do that that's some [ __ ] gumption
right there they're like that's some
entrepreneurial spirit you can get
addicted to kid to just that just just
the dust sweepings off the bottom of the
cart yeah came out the bottom we could
like monetize this yeah make people like
snort it up well if you saved it up you
know after some shipments it might be
[ __ ] ten pounds of that [ __ ] you know
make some money but you were addicted to
it they were sniffing it yeah because
you know what I mean the dust did blow
up one I don't think I could go that far
like I said I used to smoke yeah so I
could I get that but it's like I don't
know that's that's just - it's a hard
hit it's like taking a big long drag off
a cigarette you do get a hit of nicotine
yeah it's a rush I was right to your
head yeah yeah weird
yeah but it does make you sneeze man
that's right that's like I said it
that's like when I put too much pepper
on some [ __ ] or I put too much cinnamon
in the coffee or something goes up my
nose and sneezing yeah I just feel like
that all areas yeah well yeah don't
[ __ ] start that awesome you can do
snow I don't I stopped all tobacco's
don't don't do the [ __ ] I'm just a
cha oh do you that that's [ __ ] that
[ __ ] burnout chose not the same as
sure actually comes in a brick I tried I
know that's my grandpa yeah that [ __ ]
tasted terrible I didn't like it it was
kind of unsweetened it didn't really
have any kind of flavor but like some of
the stuff like some of the chew like
lancaster was like it was it came in a
black bag it was like chew and shred
ethic it was like chewing chewing
shredded raisins
that's how good ah
reasons are disguise like a mixture of
raisins in Tubac [ __ ] raisins so hard I
have that [ __ ] all do you feel like
you're going back to [ __ ] 1849 with
your last [ __ ] a pan for gold [ __ ] yeah
you're sitting around the fire boy
living outside spitting on people's
boots of [ __ ] take a pot helmet off and
put it on the ground like that you spin
it
[ __ ] pemmican or that's what I mean
it's like cuz you're going on the trail
and [ __ ] yeah whatever big old [ __ ]
beat like I said the sidetrack show it's
not helped at all it's like for time
we're talking about a serial killer and
now we're suddenly just talking about
[ __ ] yeah it's just it's chewing
tobacco I'm drinking well you know
that's that's alright people it's as
long as people are entertained yeah just
be entertained
yeah I'm drinking um no what people
check this out what are what are you
doing drinking tequila yeah well yeah
usually silver tequila and a juice
called maracuja which is as we call it
in Brazil it's it's passionfruit I got
that [ __ ] at Walmart during the pandemic
and it was cheap to the guys [ __ ] ton of
it because Did you touch stuff in
Walmart did you yeah why they were gonna
give me diseases white people don't know
anything about Walmart they don't know
it I didn't I don't mean Walmart I was
gonna say white people know everything
about I say white people when Brazilians
are white [ __ ] around Americans don't
know anything about [ __ ] passion
fruit and passion fruit juice it's like
a parallel dimension orange juice but it
doesn't kind of comes from of fruits
nothing like an orange it's more like a
melon without any meat it's just a bunch
of seeds in it and it's those seeds that
taste like that they're beautiful and
that ice cream is [ __ ] off the chain
yeah I actually kind of and I don't
usually like fruity ice creams mmm
other than strawberries all right but
normally if I'm gonna eat ice cream I
like like chocolate or coffee or yeah
nuts
that's not girl flavors rules like that
chocolaty chocolaty a [ __ ]
guys like food stuff bird or butter
pecan or that's like old people flavor I
like that okay now butter becomes good
yeah probably zit cream and well I have
to say to that like one of the only
fruit ice creams that I like is if you
go to like a good Indian restaurant like
memories of India and late Mary they
make their own mango ice cream and it is
delicious and I don't like mangoes like
mangoes if I eat a mango like by itself
to me it tastes like perfume I have that
thing where you know how people like
some people like they have that genetic
thing where if they cilantro it tastes
like soap yeah I have a thing I don't
know if there's like a parallel thing
but every time I've eaten mango
it tastes like perfume perfume yes like
it tastes like I'm like eating perfume I
love it but um this this Indian
restaurant that we go to they make their
own mango ice cream and it is really
really good it doesn't like taste
perfumey or anything it's like really
really rich and savory it's yummy but
yeah so yeah we were talking about
Pascagoula Mississippi yeah so this is
1982 now Samuel little gets arrested
there and he's actually charged with
murder this time for a 22 year old woman
whose name was Melinda leprae now she
had been missing since September of 1982
so he did get arrested for this murder
because he was the last person that had
been seen with her like several
witnesses came forward and said hey yeah
you know she got in his car and then we
didn't see her again and she went
missing
but because the only witnesses were
other sex workers and there wasn't any
other physical evidence the grand jury
did not indict him for this person well
that's understandable there's no
evidence yeah now as you're the last
person seen with a person doesn't mean
yeah that doesn't necessarily she's
she's a prostitute she's seeing all
kinds of guys yeah she might have like
met someone right now while he was under
investigation for this particular murder
however
you got transferred to Florida because
he was suspected in yet another murder
this was the murder of a 26 year old
woman named Patricia and mount now her
body was found in September of 1982
again
Samuel little was the last person who
had been seen with her before she
disappeared but again because the
witnesses were sex workers and/or drug
addicts the jury did not believe them or
did not think that their testimony was
credible so he actually did end up going
to trial but he ended up getting
acquitted of the murder in January of
1984 now we should probably take a break
at this moment cuz I think we're at the
1 hour mark and yeah it did actually
well like I said cuz we went off on a
million times house well like how much
more the case we got that's that way
through the case um yeah it's probably
about right there so alright you know
what I mean it'll be ok you guys are on
this ride with us anyway you got nowhere
to go you're you're under lockdown it's
a pandemic it's this your pocket and
emic yeah it's the Omega man out there
oh it's really weird because it's like
it's weird because it's it's a pandemic
and you're not supposed to go out inside
and stuff like that but it's like I I
don't leave the house except early in
the morning you know I go for my no
power walk along the trail there and
there's a zillion people like out like
walking dogs ride bikes jogging because
a lot of people live around here and
they're probably like sick of sitting in
their house and that's kind of the only
place you can go where it's like outside
and you could still stay like it's a
boring friendly pandemic oh wait yeah
that's what I mean so it's like really
weird because in a lot of ways it
doesn't seem at least where we are it
doesn't seem that unusual because it
seems like a normal kind of thing like
I'm going out and there's like tons of
people like jogging and walking nobody
seems to be under any stress either so I
guess thank gosh it worked out with
their jobs in there and their landlords
they're just gonna hold everything
together
I guess although what it like I was
thinking about that too cuz I was like
well what would that look like I mean
cuz I'm kind of stressed out too you
know I'm sure a lot of people are
stressed out because even like a lot of
our friends that I've heard
like you know I've lost their jobs and
or don't know if they have a job to go
back to like you know they don't know if
like the place they worked it's gonna
open back up again so it's kind of like
but I but I don't know what I would
expect like I don't know like I'm out
walking like in the morning it's like I
don't know if I'm expecting somebody
like walking their dog or something to
just be like oh my god oh my god there's
like no one's doing that obviously
everyone's just walking around like a
normal person these numbers Man United
States has proven itself to be a very
disciplined [ __ ] society
I thought they which I never would have
thought I'd have thought they'd gone
apeshit by now these numbers are looking
pretty good and I think once everything
opens back up people are gonna work
together to get this [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my
god you know what I mean it's like that
actually kind of surprised me because I
thought because you know what a lot of
Americans are like it's like if you tell
them to do something they're like [ __ ]
you man I'm not doing that I'm not doing
it
well cause like look at all those stupid
[ __ ] spring breakers and like the
[ __ ] governor of Florida he wouldn't
close the beaches until after spring
break because he's like no we need all
the tourist money and blah blah blah and
it's like then we have all these [ __ ]
retards from all over the country like I
don't care about the pandemic I'm out
here spreading disease Bieber blah [ __ ]
you [ __ ] and I was just like god
damn it
but after that happened like it really
did seem like most people like crack
down and started taking it seriously
which actually surprised me because I
didn't think that people would do that I
thought most people were at first they
just didn't give it a thought they
thought was a joke yeah which you know I
I guess I understand that but you know
now that everyone is taking it seriously
it seems like most people are on the
same page so that actually kind of
surprised me that ever that most people
are actually doing what they're supposed
to time has plummeted I never thought
that that would happen I never thought
that would happen because like there's
limits to this because like I said like
a lot of Americans it's like they kind
of have a lot of faith and I don't mean
this is like in a bad way but a lot of
them have like the mentality of like a
toddler where it's like we tell them not
to do something they'll do the opposite
well that's their superpower though
America so keep the basa me yeah that's
what makes America happen which you know
in some ways that's good like in some
situations that good that's good in this
situation it's not good so I I'm glad to
see that most people are like kind of
going along
and like being cool and everything um
you know I don't I don't know if like if
you guys have seen some [ __ ] like where
you living stuff but it does seem like
most people are kind of like trying to
work together and yeah trying to be cool
and everything like that because every
you know everybody's in the same
situation it's not like in a way maybe
that's good because everybody can relate
to everyone else's issues it's not just
kind of like oh this is just affecting
one group of people we don't give a [ __ ]
about them this is affecting everybody
yeah so maybe that's what it is so maybe
that like kind of brings out people's
[ __ ] will see yeah but we'll see um
all right so we're gonna take a break we
will be back in just a few minutes and
talk some more about the crimes of
allegedly the most prolific serial
killer in the United States thus far
Samuel little we'll be back in just a
second what's happening paper cookie
yeah you're not into it aren't you I
know yeah daddy's in the other room
oh you're gonna eat that yep she's also
chew on wood things okay bye host watch
you just mind taking a little nap and
cuz you were up all night waking mommy
and daddy up at 5:00 in the morning she
was out of treats to be fair so she had
to bang on the window til we put some in
the pool and then she jumped up on Tom's
chest and like head-butted him like
thank you you love true crime
I love true crime and I've spent the
last three years compiling a series of
the most intriguing unsolved murders of
the 20th century it's called the
faceless villain and volume 3 is
available now featuring such fascinating
cases as the Caddy murders the carry
baby's case
the Frog boys the al-qasr murders and
the inokashira park dismemberment
incident the faithless villain volume
three is an involving exploration of
unsolved slang spanning the years from
1980 to 1999 pick up your copy and print
or eBook formats on Amazon or download
the audiobook version from audible.com
and get ready for a chilling journey
through modern crime history
all right we're back from the break
talking about serial killer
Samuel little do you refill your drinkin
oh yeah yeah you're good to go
um I guess so I have the letter I have
some left I can pour you some of this if
you want let me know you don't like
tequila try touch it with that with that
Kayla come on man up I don't want you
man enough I don't want you get to man
it's not like you want me to go yeah you
get too manly on me and then I might
have to break up with actually you know
I try to peg me with some [ __ ] so all
right now all of our drinks have been
yeah I wished made her a drink but I had
to leave that I had to leave that stuff
in because she didn't because that's
funny yeah I want me getting manly and
like doing that guys you might try to
peg me or some [ __ ] like that yeah
knowing me a problem all right whatever
you love it
so uh when we last left our serial
killer Samuel little he had just been
acquitted of the murder of Patricia and
mount in January of 1984 now after he
got acquitted of this particular murder
he moved out to California and ended up
staying in various places around San
Diego usually in motels or he would like
to stay with people or whatever now he
wasn't in San Diego for very long before
he got arrested once again this was in
October of 1984 he gets arrested for
kidnapping beating and strangling a 22
year old woman named Lori barrows do you
now she actually lived so she reported
the [ __ ] they did actually kind of take
it seriously but they can find him at
the time however a month after the
attack on Lori barrows Samuel little was
found in the backseat of his car with
another unconscious woman who had also
been beaten up
and strangled this was the same in the
same place as as where Laurie
barrows had been attacked so finally the
cops are kind of like oh okay well maybe
we have a problem here so he got
arrested and charged with both of the
crimes however he only served two and a
half years in prison again this is
another thing where I'm all forgiving
lenient sentences for you know drug [ __ ]
or like you know [ __ ] this non-violence
[ __ ] but you beat up and rape a woman
and like she's like unconscious in your
car two times within a month you gotta
go I feel like you need to get more than
two and a half years
no you need to be killed I'm just saying
because you let a [ __ ] like that
run around she's gonna get your wife
your daughter your friend's daughter
your friend's wife a menace to society
once you've done it two or three times I
feel like there's a pattern emerging you
gotta go and just adjust and you need to
be taken off of the streets for the
safety of everyone involved at least
that yeah yeah I'm just saying so so a
lot of a lot of people drop the ball in
this situation is all I'm saying I'm not
pointing fingers at anyone in particular
I'm just saying that a lot of you know
police districts in this case I know he
moved around a lot I know they didn't
have the [ __ ] technology back then
but the system the prison system all
that just could we got it so he just
fell through the cracks as we got into
this kind of [ __ ] many times on the show
law enforcement wasn't wasn't what it
was you know back then this was early
80s yeah so you know forensic technology
yeah computer technology wasn't there
the wall and they weren't yeah they
weren't like cooperating other precincts
it's like it was all around you could
[ __ ] and that seems to be like what
he was doing and like we said if you
preyed on victims that were not
particularly quote-unquote valuable
individuals right then you could pretty
much operate with impunity it seems like
they called that people on the margins
of society
exactly and um you know you're smarter
serial killers they do like a little um
he seemed to know that targeting those
people would keep him off the radar and
he was correct because he didn't get
caught until like four decades after he
started like killing people so he gets
two and a half years for both of these
crimes he gets released in February 1987
and moves to Los Angeles now when he
moved to Los Angeles it is believed that
he killed at least ten more people in LA
that's a whole serial killer [ __ ]
serial killers have not yet even gotten
tapped man yeah that's a whole career
right there that's what I mean this dude
has killed
I believe it like like I said like a lot
of these serial killers that it's like
oh I killed this than the other person
and like they like to inflate their
tally for like some fucked-up reason
this guy I don't think he's inflating it
yeah he he remembers killing 93 people I
buy it yeah I think he really did kill
all those people and they just don't um
you know they just haven't matched all
of them up yet I mean the FBI seem to
think and they know more about it than I
do because they're like not releasing a
lot of the details and [ __ ] but they're
like we don't have any reason to doubt
his confessions because most of them
we've been able to match to particular
cases that were unsolved you know and
there's no reason that he would know any
of these details so 93 people probably
and like I said he seems to remember
them pretty well although he's getting
old now he's almost 80 he has diabetes
he's in a wheelchair I'm not saying that
likes it for you to feel sorry for him
I'm just saying that he might CAC soon
yeah and he's trying to get it off his
chest yeah and like some families might
not get closure and he's in anyway yes
well I mean on the other side of that
like I know that like a lot of the
families of the victims
might want him to be you know formally
convicted of the murder of their
relative but one he's old and he's
really sickly it's like - how much money
do we want to spend since he's already
in prison he's never getting out it's
like if he confessed to it and you know
that he did it I mean I would hope that
that was enough closure that way they
could at least clear it off the books
and they know what happened and they
know what happened to those people it's
like it would take too long to do all
those trials he'll be dead by the time
your that's kind of what I feel because
he looks like he's really not in good
shape he can't even walk anymore like he
they're just like carting him around and
he would take a good 10 15 years to get
through that many cases yeah exactly
that's like you know it's very very slow
so I so I don't really think yeah so now
he is just like running around killing
people for all this time now he doesn't
get arrested for the final time until
September of 2012
now they had already started to suspect
by this point that he might be involved
in a lot more murders that they and that
he was involved in a lot more cold cases
than than they had initially suspected
now he was arrested in a homeless
shelter like some Christian mission or
something like that in Louisville
Kentucky by authorities in California
they wanted to extradite him back to
California and they had him because he
had like run off on some [ __ ]
narcotics charge but they since they
suspected him and a bunch of murders in
California they just wanted to get him
back in the state you know I mean so
they were using that because they knew
that that was like you know a thing that
they could get him on so they arrest him
in Kentucky at a homeless shelter they
bring him back to California to face the
drug charges and then ViCAP
you know the violent Criminal
Apprehension program or whatever whose
only job it is is to like scour through
like cold cases and like try to match
them to like DNA profiles of you know
criminals that are on file because
they're trying to like clear all the
cold cases that's like their whole
entire purpose
they had gotten a bunch of hits on his
DNA because they were checking like some
back some old cold cases and stuff so
they determined through DNA once he was
back in California they determined that
he was involved in three cases that were
unsolved in Los Angeles now these were
the murders of Carole Alford who was
murdered in July of 1987
Guadalupe Apodaca apodaca who was
murdered in September of 1987 and Audrey
Everett who was killed in August of 1989
these women were had all been murdered
in Los Angeles and just like found in
the streets they were all sex workers
and his DNA was found on all of them so
they had some [ __ ] to like hold him on
now the more he was into so they take
him to Los Angeles right and he gets
formally charged with these three
murders in January of 2013
now as a couple months later they kind
of came out and said okay well he's also
being investigated for about 12 other
murders that took place in the 1980s
although they didn't give like any
further details they just kind of came
out and said we suspect this dude is
responsible for many more murders than
you know what the DNA shows just because
like all of this like his MO was similar
like all this other kind of stuff and
they like tracked where he was and all
this other kind of stuff
now at this stage the case of Melinda
leprae who he had been arrested for
committing in Mississippi but was not
indicted because there wasn't enough
evidence they reopened that case because
they suspected that he might have been
responsible for that as well and then
they started testing him for all these
other like unsolved murders around the
country so his trial starts for the
murders of the three women in particular
that they had DNA evidence for that
started in September of 2014 now
in September of 2014 he gets found
guilty of those three murders and gets
sentenced to life in prison without any
possibility of parole now at this stage
he's still saying he's innocent and he
doesn't know any of these women he
doesn't know what they're talking about
yada yada but there was DNA evidence
everything all the evidence was there in
these three particular cases so they
were able to secure a conviction he got
life you know no parole so he's put away
after that though he's in prison for a
few years now they suspect that he might
have started confessing one because he
was in bad health like I said he's a
diabetic and he can't really walk
anymore like he you know he has to go
around in a wheelchair he also has heart
problems so they don't know if it's
because he thinks he's dying or because
he wanted to get transferred out of the
prison in Los Angeles which he didn't
like because it was like noisy and
crowded and everything but he started
confessing to like all these other
murders in all these other states and
eventually ended up getting extradited
back to Texas for a murder that he had
committed there so he starts in November
of 2018 which is why there's like not a
lot of info about this case yet because
it's still very much an open
investigation and he only started
confessing in late 2018 to all the [ __ ]
that he had probably done he starts
confessing to all these other murders
which like I said a lot of serial
killers do that just to like you know
pump up their victim number and stuff
like that but this guy it was kind of
different because he seemed to remember
very particular details about every
single crime even if he couldn't
remember exactly where it happened like
when it happened he was very good about
remembering oh I was driving this car it
was in this city like I met this person
at this bar or a bar that was on this
street or somewhere around there
like he remembered enough details that
they could like look back into the cases
and like match them up with actual
unsolved homicides
so November of 2018 he confesses to a
strangling a woman named ELISA Thomas
that happened in 1996 he also got
charged with another murder of a woman
named Denise Brothers that was in Odessa
Texas in 1994 and I should say too that
there was like a Texas Ranger named
James Holland and he's kind of like kind
of considered like the hero of the story
because he's the one that and if you
watch a lot of the interviews with him
on YouTube that's whose voice you'll
hear in the background that's James
Holland because he seemed to be really
good at getting this guy to talk um one
thing that they said and this I thought
this was really interesting one thing
one thing that they said because people
start to come in like once he started
confessing to [ __ ] like you know
authorities from all over the country
like states where he had lived like
started coming there to interview him
about cold cases that they had open
they're like don't ask him like don't
tell him to like confess to the crime
for the families because then he will
stop talking because he doesn't give a
[ __ ] about the families and if you tell
him if you say that like he'll just shut
up and then he'll just let just despite
you I guess yeah those family yeah
because he doesn't think that the
victims it's really weird because I
don't it's hard to like tell because
there's not a lot of footage of him
there's like some footage of him where
he's like confessing to the crimes which
is creepy because he seems so normal and
like so friendly you know I mean but
then when he starts talking about the
crimes not only DC remember them very
well and like remember the situation but
he doesn't seem terribly upset about it
he doesn't seem it just seems like
something he did and the weird thing is
that he says that he loved all these
women and that it's like I'm not really
sure what his motive is he said in one
of the interviews that I read with him
that even from a very young age he said
he remembered being a little boy like
five or six years old in school and
becoming obsessed with women's necks
because that's how he killed almost all
his victims it was strangling them and
he's like when I was a little kid I had
this teacher and she used to like you
know when she would touch her neck or
something like that he's like that
really like you know that turned me on
he said quote unquote it made my dick
hard so he seemed to be like aware of
some weird neck finish I guess so
it really does seem so he even said
later on that like he was able to not
kill people that he loved by not looking
at their necks because if he looked at
their necks then he would just want to
kill them it's really weird like Dracula
yeah he had like this weird sexual thing
where he had now the thing too is that
I've read some sources that said that he
was maybe impotent
yeah but that he got that he got
sexually aroused by the strangling
because some of the bodies did have
semen on them right but not usually
inside the body was usually outside the
body so they think that while he was
strangling they were after he strangled
them that he jerked off on the bodies
because that was like how he was getting
off they were watching him his
performing yeah might have been
something like that so like I don't know
like some of the things that he said it
sounded like he was implying that he was
impotent yeah if you guys aren't regular
listeners I have this [ __ ] theory
that a lot of guys that are basically
kind of like necrophiles they they can
only have sex with a person after
they're dead or rendered unconscious
because it alleviates performance
anxiety yeah because I'm with no is one
right or they don't like they're jerking
off to a magazine or they don't have to
worry about like doing anything for that
Russ and like they don't have to worry
about like well they don't have any they
don't have any fear of making any kind
of mistakes or by disapproved of or
trying to they don't have to worry about
satisfying somebody else it's just write
them and
and their little fantasy in their little
jerk think about how much better this
world would be if they all just bought
sex dolls and left everyone else alone
the day will come I guess the day will
come when when the sex cells are so like
cheap and realistic that you can just
have one of those and not be a serial
killer that would be awesome
but yeah so there would be a lot of
women out of job who knows well that's
alright then there'll be male sex dolls
to it look like damn
Korean pop stars you know what though I
feel like they won't sell as well it's
right 11 don't give a [ __ ] no they don't
know well that's the thing it's like you
know when you know there was playboy and
that was like a big success and then
they did Playgirl yeah um but it mostly
wasn't women that were buying that it
was gay men that was yeah and I don't
think that that's what they expect only
for women like damn this romance novels
we like erotica erotic I like written
around it and written Paul like I said
we we like to use our imaginations yeah
we don't we don't like to just like look
at them cuz I'm like who the [ __ ] is
that
oh no they don't really have
imaginations they don't I've noticed
like a shark it's all just extrasensory
oh yeah I've noticed that as well but
yeah so that that's why I just I thought
that was very funny that they that they
actually thought that women would buy
porn magazines was like joke
I I bought one one time like as a gag
gift for somebody that's the only time
I've ever bought one yeah cuz like why
the hell would I ever say like I like
erotica like written erotica but it's
like it doesn't need pictures I mean
pictures I got it I got a brain I could
minner i focused there I say visual
visually centered yeah yeah that's how
it looks but yeah so so this Texas
Ranger pretty much got this guy to like
confess to all this [ __ ] um so same a
little he pleads guilty to the murder of
Denise brothers that was in December of
2018 and he got another life sentence
for that and then um they you know the
people in Texas like in a [ __ ] Ector
County Ector County whatever the hell
it's called where he was being
extradited that's where he wanted to be
moved
because like I said he didn't want to be
in prison in LA anymore he would rather
go in like he was tired of the LA scene
I guess he wanted to go like be in this
prison and taxes because it was like
quieter I suppose because it was crowded
because it was like a smaller town or
whatever so um so they moved him there
and he started confessing to other
murders and they surmised that he may
have committed as I said 93 murders
across anywhere from 14 and 19 states
between 1970 and 2005 hmm he also
confessed to a murder that happened in
1979 which was Brenda Alexander she was
23 years old that was in Phoenix City
Texas he was also suspected to have
killed a woman in Macon Georgia in 1977
this was an identified woman also he
admitted to strangling a woman who was
18 years old named Fredonia Smith that
was in 1982 he also confessed to another
1982 murder 55 year old Dorothy Richard
and the 1996 murder of Daisy McGuire it
was 40 years old now this was both of
those murders were in Houma Houma
Louisiana whoo mama that's what I
thought now when he was in Mississippi
because like I said he went all over the
[ __ ] States he had strangled a woman
named Julia Critchfield it was 36 years
old that was in the Gulfport he dumped
her body off a cliff in 1978 he also
admitted to killing Nancy Stevens who
was 46 in Tupelo that was in 2005 the
king would not approve no I would hope
not
um he also killed a 19 year old girl
named Evelyn watt Weston now hold on one
second what you said he threw a girl off
a cliff in Gulfport I'm trying to think
of where the cliffs are in golf course
maybe not a cliff I was like on board
I'm just trying to where's no cliffs and
go I'd like to see where this was well
as maybe off a rock or something yeah
okay I would think yeah just a clip on
Wikipedia so I don't really know okay
yeah it's kind of like Florida it's like
we don't really have any cliffs but yeah
we have hills and [ __ ] yeah Gulfport all
the Florida's very flat and in case if
we have no mountains it's sea level it
has beach there Gulfport and then it
goes into forest where it's like a swamp
where sea water is up against damn trees
it's the weirdest thing in the world
it looks like fresh water but it's sea
water yeah we have some places like that
here yeah like the Everglades yeah yeah
it's like dad something but there's no
cliffs there someone what the [ __ ]
you're talking about yeah well like I
said maybe maybe he just meant like yeah
maybe use my leg off of side of a
[ __ ] hill or right or something right
yeah so like I said he also killed the
19 year old and Evelyn Weston that was
in South Carolina that was in 1978 and
killed a 20 year old woman named Rosie
hill that was in Marion County Florida
in 1982 yes he killed some people here
as well so as I said in late 2018 the
violent Criminal Apprehension program or
ViCAP as it is better known they had
actually confirmed 34 of Samuel littles
confessions and we're trying to match
the rest of his confessions to known
cold cases around the country you know
states where he remembered that he had
been one of the confessions that he made
also was a one that happened in Maryland
and it was a identified victim this was
actually one of those in Prince County
Maryland and apparently this was one of
only two murders with unidentified
victims that had ever happened in this
particular County and he confessed to
one of them so may 34 this is so like I
said this is very recent that's why
there's like not a lot of info on this
and why this is still like an ongoing
investigation so May of 2019 in Ohio
Koya hoga
they had a like for they brought more
they brought forth more indictments like
former counts of aggravated murder six
counts of kidnapping
they also accused Samuel little of
killing a woman named Mary Jo Payton in
1984 and a woman named Rose Evans in
1991 both of those were in Cleveland
they had both been strangled and dumped
he strangled almost all of his victims I
believed if I believed a few of them he
drowned as well but most of them were
strangled because he had that next
fetish thing Oh another thing I forgot
to mention too is that I don't he kind
of implied that God told him to do it I
don't know if he meant that God told me
to do it or coz some other [ __ ] that he
said to like during his interviews was
that well God knows that he's doing that
[ __ ] and so it must be okay that's kind
of like what I got from it like he was
not stopping me so he's just think it's
all right just the same guy that would
say that he could see the devil in them
no okay there's another black guy who
used to say that he could see the devil
in them and he would go after him yeah
the weird thing about it is that he said
that I loved all these women and now
they're with me forever
he's like said [ __ ] like that keeping
him he's good it's a good way to keep
him from cheating on you
- they're prostitutes though it's like
[ __ ] yeah it's like it's just really
weird but it's like he's just weird
because he comes off like you know if
you go and watch like you know snippets
of interviews with him like on YouTube
because there are a few it's like he
comes across as like he's not creepy at
all not really I mean what he says is
creepy but his demeanor is not creepy
he's talking [ __ ] he comes across as
like very normal and like the way that
he's talking about these particular
women that he murdered it's almost kind
of like he's not bragging exactly but
it's kind of like it amuses him like to
think about it he's like yeah she was
the big
she was so pretty and blood looked like
it's just it's very weird what choices
does he have he's talking about these
women is he gonna say I hated them
[ __ ] they're all hope they're all
hoes and [ __ ]
now that might reflect badly on him okay
so what he does is he says no I loved
him I cared about those women yeah that
way he comes across like he's a good
person
in reality what is this he can give a
[ __ ] he just shine it bust a nut yeah
yeah that's that's what's really
happening he's just trying to add a
different element to it I tried to make
himself look a little bit better in
front of the authorities that's what I
think it's just very strange like if you
and and if you watch cuz you probably
haven't like watched anything like
YouTube I've seen
yes stuff but it you'll see what I'm
talking about if you watch him
that's my estimation of the situation he
comes across as very he just comes
across like a grandpa
it's like talking about some shenanigans
he got up to when he was younger he's
trying to cash in on his success but not
a new guy getting kind of way it's not
he he doesn't seem like he's bragging
he's trying to act humble he's bragging
it's it I don't buy it I know but it's
like he doesn't come across like he's
not comes where I'll say of it I've been
studying this type of personality for
too long there's not a big difference
between them they're all you know I mean
in terms of motivation and motives it's
all camouflage yeah you can't trust what
they say you can't go with appearances
you know with serial killers the truth
is is that he either hated the women or
he didn't give a [ __ ] but he's just I
have a feeling that he didn't just
didn't give it try just didn't really
give a [ __ ] he thought they were shitty
and the he could kill he could kill him
and do his little thing on them and get
away with it and then afterwards he's
like man I'm [ __ ] slick as [ __ ] I
could do whatever I want cuz like all he
would say was just like he would talk
about like all this [ __ ] that he was
doing and then he'd be like man [ __ ] was
crazy yeah it was so crazy he can't say
that to the authority wants to confess
everybody knows what he did he can't say
you can't tell the truth because they'll
come back on a mic now man you piece of
[ __ ] no make him feel bad
yeah they'll attack him so he has to
make himself more presentable I cared
about him don't know why I did it but I
care about love their necks yes yeah cuz
like I said some of these women like one
of the women in particular who I'm
thinking of who was actually she was a
white woman yeah and she like a he said
that he that she approached him like he
was like parks like behind a bar
restaurant or something and she was like
kind of a hippie and she needed a ride
like to Miami and he spent like two or
three days with her in the car and then
he just decided I'm just gonna strangle
her couldn't take it anymore he had to
get his rocks off yeah it's just like
it's the weirdest thing he doesn't come
across like a serial killer at all which
isn't killing and having that dead body
is the sex
he's basic I think you know what you're
talking about you're talking about like
a a modified necrophile they've got a
dick yeah he doesn't have sex with the
dead body but the dead bodies with him
when he's had a sex he's masturbating on
the thing okay it does seem like he's
trying but he want he feels this an
accomplishment he wants to take credit
for it and wants everybody to know that
it was him before he dies and he doesn't
want to be attacked and he doesn't want
people to think he's a bad person he
wants to go to respect him so he says he
loves them yeah because that's just how
I'm seeing him that's how I'm seeing it
but it was a power play and it's all
about him it's like now they all belong
to me now because I remember that you
see here it is he's dying he's getting
old right but it still it's all about
him yeah confessions are about him yeah
of course they're not about the family
or the victim or anything yeah he's
basking in the glory and the attention
see that really does seem like it you
know even as you know I don't really
want to use the word likable but some
serial killers do come across as like
not not as creepy as some of the other
ones but even the more likeable of them
they do seem to make everything about
them yeah they're very like
so this thinks he's czar oh yeah you
know that's that's who he thinks he is
he's got a fantasy image of himself I
mean all like all he would ever say it's
like he's very matter-of-fact about like
saying you know yeah this girl came up
to me and I did this says she wanted it
right in Miami and I liked it and then I
just strangled her and I throw and he
like remembers everything he's like yeah
I you know strangled her and I dragged
her and put her in this road and he
remembers in city it was what car was
and all this other kind of stuff and
it's like but he doesn't like embellish
it he doesn't it that's what's like so
weird about it he's just very well
there's two things I think happening in
their mind one they want to bass get it
this is kind of like the dude scores a
touchdown and then he deuce that does
the damn dance yeah damn it cuz they
can't punish him he's too old now
there's nothing they can do to him so
he's now free of their justice so he
wants to [ __ ] do his victory dance on
the goal line you know but he also did
he also wants to kind of like I think
there's a certain part in them there's
that they want to get think they want to
get the guilty feelings because I think
they do have some guilt they want to get
that off of them and you see bringing it
out into the open and no longer have to
have the burden of carrying the secrecy
yeah so to become liberated from their
own little secrets you know and and I
think in some way they feel that they're
being approved of because people are
listening to them and there's no
punishment punishment can't come
so therefore yeah because they've
already been punished where there's
nothing more they can yeah so she might
let yourself off the hook that's what it
is it's letting yourself off the hook
yeah that's probably exactly what it is
yeah because that's how I'm imagining
like I said I mean as you know I know
like like in Amadeus Salieri
in this wheelchair you know that's what
that's what you would understand that
there's that
that analogy but that's what it's like
we need to review that hello that's one
of my finale area and going yeah he's
better he's the patron saint of media
yeah Mozart I love that [ __ ] [ __ ] can
I kill you I've seen it a million times
yeah we got to see I got to get that
[ __ ] on blu-ray I have it on DVD but I
think it's in the Attic somewhere that
was the Dino fun fact that was the first
DVD I ever bought like the DVD was a new
format because that was that is one of
my favorite movie was watchable as [ __ ]
when I was a kid I watched it about 20
times it's [ __ ] great yeah it's
[ __ ] great I love that movie so much
yeah I even read like that movie like
got me super interested in Mozart like
all this stuff about Sally heard that
shit's not true it was just like basic
good movie play and stuff but Mozart's
life was actually really interesting and
I got like all into like interested in
like his sister who was just as talented
her name was Lynn Durrell and she was
just like just as talented as him but of
course she was a girl so it's like they
didn't nobody talked about that so it's
like she did all the same [ __ ] as him
when he was a kid you know cuz their dad
Leopold would like take them around and
tour them around Europe and stuff and
like hey performing children look
they're like you know musical prodigies
but once she got to the age where she
could be like married off and stuff they
just did that to her yeah but you know
what I mean she was times work yeah
exactly but uhm yeah it's like really
like an interesting story if anybody so
we should but seriously we should yeah
but that's what he's doing he's doing
his Salieri moment that's that's what I
think it yeah it does seem like that but
like I said watch the [ __ ] and you'll
see what I'm talking about but he does
come across as like a very like you can
see why a lot of women like not just sex
workers not just maybe they wouldn't
have been threatened by him he doesn't
come across as threatening maybe he did
when he was younger I mean he's a big
dude but he comes across as very
personable and very friendly and you
know he's a good talker easy like yeah
another thing he just comes across as
like a good guy
if I said he was cool that's what I mean
so it's like which scares the [ __ ] out
of me because now I wanted like talked
to him
or because I'm watching this guy I'm
just like hey he seems pretty cool oh
yeah he's a serial killer
don't worry I got you back I'll sniff
them [ __ ] out I just I I have
just got to the point like I'm almost 50
years old I've gotten to the point now
where I'm just kind of like trust no one
yeah I don't care how friendly they seem
just trust no one I just assume
everyone's a serial killer
no I don't well it's you know I've
written enough to your crimes now
there's a certain feeling you're gonna
get but you might not but you might not
they're mostly involved in [ __ ] bad
business to begin with look at the
situation they're not moving in real
good circles you don't marry in the same
circles we move in I mean that we need
lots of people that do some Ross some
bad [ __ ] but it's just like normal bad
[ __ ]
normal batches yeah you know the
movement and drugs DEA another thing
many larceny yeah we know we know we
know bad people but they're good people
they're just dumb yeah it's like I don't
I don't they're not evil I don't think
anyone we know is a serial killer I'm
pretty sure I would be very surprised
know if anybody we know is a serial
killer like I said I wouldn't be
surprised to hear some other things
yeah but serial killer now but then
that's what they all say though isn't it
like every time somebody gets caught as
a serial killer all their neighbors and
friends are alike worried about it too
much they're usually of constantly on
the move they're [ __ ] kind of zephir
BTK they're kind of nerdy they're not
doing too well in life they're not
regulars in any kind of scene they're
just you know I mean they're not they
don't have extended relationships with
other people in other words they're not
part of crowds or scenes we kind of have
our own little community around here
your honor man so we know who's who
yeah everybody knows everybody and if
any does their due and if anybody does
anything [ __ ] up every rose
and they report because it everybody
talks yeah we're like some of the first
I mean the thing is like out of that
entire [ __ ] scene that we're in we're
like the most respected ones we're like
everybody's mom and dad yeah they kind
of tell us that yeah we're like thinking
we're like your [ __ ] mom and dad the
see it's because we don't get any
trouble that's right yeah and we don't
cause like in a Cosmo we're not trying
to [ __ ] other people's [ __ ]
boyfriends or girlfriends and for gonna
do my drama and [ __ ] that they do but a
lot of them have gotten a lot of gotten
older in the past ten yes so love that
smell
we're not the oldest we're among the
oldest but there are some there are some
that are in the scene that are older
than I yeah but yeah we do get called a
like [ __ ] even at I bar which I hope
reopens because I would hate for me to
not ever be able to go back there again
yeah but um Liat I've already stabbed
our manager yeah he calls his mom and
dad
yeah and I got dude sucking reporting to
me you know that I'm joining the Navy
I'm joining the army just I'm like dude
go ahead and do your [ __ ] thing I'm
button and then I'm reporting back to me
like I'm their dad and I realize a lot
of them don't have dads so maybe I am
their dad well in some of them too and
we've heard this particularly how
they're doing in the military well
particularly from some that come from
particularly like very strict families
or something it's like if you're into
the goth scene like some families even
in this day and age for Christ's sake
some families don't like it yeah um so
sometimes some of these younger people
their parents do not like them being
Goths or into the fetish scene or
whatever so some of them relate to us
better than they relate to their own
parents because we're like the age of
their parents right but we're not as
lame as they're actually so so we get
that a lot we get like a lot of the
younger ones like my parents hate me or
they kick me into the house or they
don't listen to me or anything like that
so we try to give them like advice and
[ __ ] from our crotchety old boy
actually we don't have a crotchety old
crotchety is the old people from my town
when I was a kid well yeah no [ __ ]
as people couldn't function today I
honestly I told myself even from going
back to when I was 12 or 13 years old I
said I'm never gonna be like that I just
don't ever want to be like that my
grandparents generation they'd be there
they would be non-functional I don't
want to be in like I know like
physically I'll be an old person but I
don't want to mentally be an old person
and I told myself that when I was a
teenager we're gonna download our
consciousness into the Internet will
live on it I want to download my
consciousness into like a new hot body
yeah and a robot body in a river they'll
have all that probably I don't know if
hopefully they'll like him develop that
[ __ ] before I'm too old to like take
advantage if you like son I am into that
I see like something out of damn
Battlefield Earth bunch of bodies that I
could choose from whereas getting
sidetracked again that's on the case
quite a bit okay
well not like not quite a bit okay
alright so Sam little has also confessed
to killing one woman in Akron Ohio two
women in Cincinnati two of the women
that he murdered in Cincinnati they
actually know who this woman are a lot
of his victims are unidentified sadly
and that's why the FBI is trying to like
put out these sketches that he did he
does these sketches
they're super creepy you guys it's like
he does them in these like chalk pastels
and they're like obviously he never took
a drawing class but they're good enough
that you can identify the person like if
you knew that person if you saw the
drawing of it you would say yeah that's
that person so it looks like that person
but it's like it doesn't look realistic
if that makes any sense you know what I
mean because at least one victim has
been identified from one of the drawings
and it's really weird because I saw the
drawing and it was put next to the
identified victim and to me it didn't
look that same
but apparently like even if like Friends
of the victim and the victims son who
was only a kid when his mom disappeared
he's like yeah that's my mom when he saw
the drawing to me it doesn't look that
similar but I guess it must have been
similar enough that somebody I think it
was the hair mostly that like because
she had this like very particular
hairstyle but yeah so he doesn't like
all these creepy drawings so the FBI
have like put out like a bunch of his
drawings that they encouraged him to
like draw a lot of the women that he
killed you know from his memory and he
apparently is a really good memory
because a lot of the them are very
detailed and so they're putting them out
and they're trying to like determine
like they're trying to match them up
with like cases and stuff weird so yeah
the the two women he killed in
Cincinnati one of them was Anna Stewart
who was 33
she was actually last seen in 1981 I
don't believe she was a sex worker she
was going to visit her sister like in
the hospital or something like that like
and she's getting out of a cab and then
she disappeared and then they found her
dead later on hmm I should say too this
is another guy this guy had a girlfriend
for a long time I don't know how long
they were together he called her Jean um
I have a picture of the two of them
together she was a lot older than he was
she was um a little bit of a criminal
too like he would steal [ __ ] and she
would like fence it you know what I mean
I don't think she knew about the murders
necessarily or I don't yeah like I would
probably and put up with that this to
his heat besides that he could turn on
her but she probably did that's what I
mean like I don't think well she died of
[ __ ] I don't remember what she died of
it was some kind of cancer lonoa brain
aneurysm she died of a brain aneurism
see so yeah as far as we know she didn't
get killed by him but apparently she
like sold a lot of [ __ ] that he stole
hmm but that's the thing though it's
like and we talked about this like with
a lot of serial killers that had
families like
BTK and stuff like that you know where's
the point where because I think there's
kind of a segment of people that are
like oh well if your husband or your dad
as a serial killer you've got to know
but not necessarily like I said if I was
a kid if my dad had been a serial killer
for example he's not a serial I don't
think no he's not a serial killer
but if I'd been a little kid and he'd
been like just say going off to work
every day
I wouldn't think anything about it he
could be a leg off doing his job he used
to like install cable so he's to like
drive around in the [ __ ] cablevision
truck like BTK used to do in his [ __ ]
we're seeing how long your grass is or
your dog catcher truck or whatever and
it's like if you were out like [ __ ]
stalking people and murdering them off -
how the [ __ ] would I know
and I feel like the wife's don't know
you don't know that either yeah
how much do you really know about like
the person that you live with especially
if they go out to work every day yeah
keep it secret you don't know what
they're doing if you can fool around on
a woman that you can kill another one
exactly it's the same exactly and less
yeah it's right easier to kill a woman
and your wife not know because it's not
a continuing relationship and it doesn't
fit Gress race and there's like nothing
that there's like not like this building
like [ __ ] it's just one night stands and
you kill a person so there's no
connection right and that that's what I
mean so that's [ __ ] up to say but it's
probably true carry like carrying on a
long-term affair with someone a lot of
guys give your probably like gonna get
caught a lot of guys get caught you know
with other women because the girlfriend
[ __ ] approaches the [ __ ] wife you
know I mean or tries to sabotage the
situation so the wife finds out yeah
he's trying to run off with the dude
yeah and she gets sick of like being
like decided you wanna be a side woman
she won't be the main woman yeah I can
see that yeah that happens a lot so so
yeah like you said I feel like you know
people maybe like cast aspersions on
serial killers wives and children and
stuff like that like oh you must have
known a bla bla bla but I don't that
essentially I don't think that's
necessarily the case it's like if
they're not killing people in your house
if they're not killing me if they go out
to work every day how the [ __ ] do you
know what they're doing what I think is
weird is that you got a guy who's
married he's got kids and he's sucking
got a perfectly normal family life he
cares about his family he's [ __ ] over
other peoples that's what not that was
my [ __ ] like in a way people's
daughters a lot of in a lot of ways like
serial killers that are just like
drifters or just like like Samuel little
like Gary Ridgway it's more like an
animal it's more understandable because
it's like they don't really have any
like you know deep connections they
don't have a family they don't have any
anything like that yeah so it's easier
for them just like oh they just kill
people and they dump them in it's like
they don't really think about it but
when you have this whole other life yeah
and you know you have a wife and kids or
whatever and they don't suspect anything
that's going on that blows my mind like
yeah he's a family man and he's [ __ ]
trying to do right by his family but
he's [ __ ] your family how can you
like compartmentalize I really don't
understand that I don't understand
people that are able to compartmentalize
to that degree they're just like a
psychopath you're a sociopath in a way
to where they just other people don't
matter they only care about their own
desires
I get overly selfish I mean BTK he had a
word for that he called it um cubing
that's what he called it he called it
like he was talking about like he had
different cubes he put that [ __ ] in a
box we yeah he was putting stuff in a
box so he calls it cubing so he would
cube into this or cube into that that
was the terminology that he used but I
don't understand like being able to do
that I really don't I I don't think most
people are starting analyzing his second
behavior yeah because he didn't want one
one one personality or one persona to to
[ __ ] infringe on the other be like
cross-contamination yeah that's the way
he talked about it have [ __ ]
conflicts where you have just now you
have to [ __ ] worry about the victims
that you killed yeah and the impact
either he doesn't wanna do that he's
gotta keep that away yeah so
everything's in its own little box and
that's what he called it cubing yeah
it's a [ __ ] personality problem that
means it's almost kind of like multiple
personalities in a way to where yeah
it's not you're not integrated into one
being great that's not No
all right no it's not normal I was gonna
say no I was like I hope not because I
don't I mean as a soldier you kind of
click into a mission mode yeah I get
that but you're with a bunch of guys and
it's a military situation and there's a
higher objective it always boils down to
we got to kill these guys so our guys
don't get you I get that so you killed
other people to protect people you know
that's really what it's about
yeah that's why you know kind of like
the holistic concept of like hey we're
all just people man and what that
doesn't [ __ ] fly with most people not
with me it's just not how it is because
you're dealing with other people that
have other motives that are contrary to
yours
and you give them a chance they will
overcome you and your society and kill
you or impose their will on you you
don't want that that's what warfare and
fighting is all about it's about
willpower you know I mean whose will
will dominate and I mean you don't want
them to be able to impose on you so
you're gonna impose on them which person
who lives a [ __ ] normal civilian life
and you know in an office that doesn't
make any sense to them because they're
not in that world but it is another way
of looking at it and that's how we look
at and it is a reality this here though
of like what BTK these other serial
killers do it's - it's not a reality
because it's too too much oriented too
much oriented towards a single person
that person you know what I mean
yeah like Dennis Rader yeah it's
oriented towards Dennis right it's like
the ultimate in [ __ ] solipsism or the
ultimate in [ __ ] ego ego but yeah all
the universe revolves around them they
do kind of have that yeah well [ __ ] them
the that's if you ask me it's that it's
overcompensation of some sort or oh [ __ ]
or it's there's something not right in
their brains people are not able to deal
with their own
insignificance right yeah I I never
really saw myself like that I always saw
myself on a tribal level that's how I
see it I care about people that I know
people that I have relationships with
yeah I mean and in the big picture when
I was in the military that was my unit
my platoon my company my regiment the
army that I was in that really meant
more to me at the time thence then
civilians or America that's not really
what we were thinking of we were
thinking about the dudes we knew it's
personalized
yah yah no man but humans are built I
think he asked me most humans are built
for a more of a tribal mentality you're
mostly just thinking about the people in
your immediate sphere yeah it may turn
it 200 people then yeah generally what's
a people and it makes more sense to see
the world that way that doesn't mean you
want everybody else to just [ __ ] off and
die like I do feel like most people have
like a larger right they do have a
larger understanding of like hey my
actions affect more than just my social
group and stuff like that especially
nowadays but most people like your brain
kind of evolved to deal with your
closest hundred two hundred two hundred
young people and I also think I also
believe um I think in this science
supports this nation is a factor or you
know might like civilization is a factor
and then to a certain degree race as a
factor and and then like you know what I
mean your immediate tribal yeah you're
not even race similarity similarity how
similar similar people here's the weird
thing about race in the military race
wasn't too much of a factor we were all
just kind of green you know Tom how well
yeah you're all like we all kind of
consider ourselves to be the same race
yeah you know and I guess you can say
that's kind of like part of nation
yeah but we had a concept of struggling
civilizations that there were different
civilizations on the earth that had
opposing values and we were being told
to sort about we didn't always agree
with it though yeah I meant is that that
was being decided by s Ilan's above
reality is what we used to call it in
other words [ __ ] that are there
so high up they're not even real like
presidents and politicians that's Allods
above reality it's what we call it
because most of their decisions actually
didn't work yeah well because and we
were talking about this earlier and
somebody commented about this on the
YouTube page it's like you get higher
ups in whatever organization and the
higher up you get the less they know
about what's going on they're very we're
down - lon
yeah and but however they're in charge
of like telling people what to do down
there even though they don't really know
what's going on I'm gonna give everybody
a [ __ ] example that maybe they will
understand okay
I was in the hundred and first Airborne
Division was in the first and three to
seven that some guys from em I came to
[ __ ] the interview us and they were in
civilian clothes so we couldn't tell
what rank they were or anything they do
that to disarm you because they want to
ask you questions they wanted to ask us
but they were asking us questions if the
enemy was shooting at you from a
building and there were civilians in
there what would you do and we're like
well we'd blow the whole [ __ ]
building down they're like but they're
civilians and they're like no they're
not if they're civilians and they'd be
helping us fight these guys that are in
the buildings and then they're like put
they're civilians mixed in with them and
then we were like and this was a dude
that I knew is a spec for just getting
ready to get out he said you go in there
and you kill some of them guys they're
all gonna [ __ ] line up behind you
that behind them and fight you no matter
who they were just like if somebody came
here to what America and started killing
Americans everyone would fight them all
right well evidently our unit failed
that test instead they chose the 75th
infantry which is the Ranger Regiment
guess where they sent him
Mogadishu guess what happened to him
they went there to feed those pea
people and when they killed the
Warlord's who stole the food they all
started an attack the US Army we pulled
out of there so we were right yeah you
know Operation Restore hope is a failure
you cannot go into another country and
shoot people and kill people and not
have them fight you that's just what's
gonna head there's gonna be
repercussions because you shoot people
you don't know who that person is
related it could be related to the other
people right all right and this is
something that person might not be a
terrorist but right s Ilan's be of above
reality do not understand this because
they're not realistic these are they're
not they're not really anything riot run
this is my told em exactly this is and
[ __ ] we told them says no matter where
you send us we're gonna kill everybody
we see and that kept us being deployed
good for you you and [ __ ] yeah and the
75th infantry went there the Rangers and
got their asses tore out of the frame
even though they are awesome soldiers
some of the best soldiers in the world
that is an unwinnable civil situation
yeah that's why all this regime change
and all this share of the past [ __ ] 30
years is a total failure and [ __ ]
privates could have told them that
privates in the army could have told
them that [ __ ] thirty years ago well
like I said listen to us I do feel like
they should listen more to people that
are in reality like you know whatever
the situation is they should listen to
people like on the ground that are
actually doing the thing yeah that they
want to because like I said I was
talking to somebody on YouTube about
this today where she was talking about
how she hated like managers that come in
and like they don't know how to do the
job that you're doing but they still
like tell you how to do your job it's
like you have to do this and it's like I
have experienced that my whole entire
professional life it's like you have
managers who don't know how to do what
you're doing they don't have the
technical expertise they don't have
anything but they're still telling you
oh well you need to do this on the other
and you try to tell them hey look we
can't do this you know in this timeframe
because this any other but they don't
want to hear that they just want it done
they don't care like that you can't do
it
no you know what I mean they just want
it done because all they care about is
their own salary their own [ __ ] you
know end game they don't care about how
yeah it takes to get there and we were
20 year old [ __ ] privates and
specialists and [ __ ] telling these mi
like no manatee you send it you send us
to another country to nation-build to
nation-build by killing people of that
country you're [ __ ] crazy you're
[ __ ] crazy they didn't learn that
from Vietnam well because like I said if
somebody came in to like just for
example to spread democracy by good
everybody yeah if somebody came into
we're all related they're all related
right there and you're gonna kill them
somebody comes into like our
neighborhood and starts killing people
let's just like just like let's bring it
down to that level some becomes in our
neighborhood and starts killing people
you're gonna go try to save them and
they're like right it's like you know oh
and then you're gonna say like oh well
they don't believe we believe that's a
word that's our neighbor though right
yes well they they like that guy they
had themselves convinced that we could
export democracy and American values by
killing people and that's just a [ __ ]
alien concept to me especially you're
trying to do this to people who
basically can't read and write
I'm not running water like democracy is
good it's just that I feel like [ __ ]
at the [ __ ] little you guys
it can't be [ __ ] four it's like
people have to come to that [ __ ] of
their own their own evolution you gotta
[ __ ] do that [ __ ] it's it you can't
like force it on people you can't yeah
and I want everybody here listen to me
to understand this is going back to the
90s back with [ __ ] Operation Restore
hope soldiers on the [ __ ] ground
we're Talent the army you're [ __ ]
crazy that's an impossible mission they
didn't listen to us
and that led directly to the Iraq war
too
the rock ward part 2 which is going in
there and get rid of ugly oh what's that
electric electric bugaloo which that was
unfortunately a lot of my [ __ ]
comrades and arms died for that [ __ ]
right there and really that was about
contracts I think they I think they
thought they could make Iraq a shining
beacon of democracy they believed that
because that's how dumb they [ __ ] are
they didn't know those people the
history and democracy isn't something
you can force on people with a [ __ ]
barrack with [ __ ] m16s and bombs it's
something that they evolved into through
their own will and there are cultures
that will you get never accept that yeah
they don't want that so there are
cultures that will never accept that
never and it's just it's just the truth
some cultures want religion they don't
want government because their religion
is a government and you can't force that
on them that's on them yeah and look at
this sidetrack man we are a [ __ ]
sidetrack like a [ __ ] we won't
well and I got military officers out
there listening to me and everything
there there are lieutenant Colonel's and
[ __ ] high-ranking military officers
that listen to me and [ __ ] talk to me
off the screen so yeah yeah after the
show so like I said it's all good well
like I said people seem to like when the
shows go longer yeah and because Samuel
little I wanted to a show about him
because he's you know according to the
FBI the most prolific serial killer in
the u.s. but there's not a lot of
information about him so I was kind of
like [ __ ] do I have enough
information for a show I think that
every single time and then he starts
talking [ __ ] on me we're not blaming I'm
just saying that no I'm good I'm being
appreciative it's like and then the show
ends up being soon I'm half three hours
long so that's good you fill it in she's
saying that I'm material I'm
entertainment material I'll clown now
I'm a clown
I thought you wanted that you wanted
that right yeah yeah I'm flimsy Oh
say no playing with you baby I never
know so what all right so um so yeah so
Samuel little is in prison now he is
confessed to a bunch of other crimes now
let's talk about just kind of as a wrap
up okay let's talk about like the five
main crimes that the FBI are
investigating at this point now these
are crimes that Samuel little has
confessed to but they have not yet
matched to any unsolved crimes now I
should note that most of his crimes that
he confessed to have been matched to
crimes around the country that they
suspect that he committed these five
have not been so you know should go
without saying but if anybody knows
anything about any of these like please
call the FBI and like tell them about it
so this these as far as I can tell this
was from the FBI website these are the
five unmatched confessions that he's
made again you can also go on YouTube
and you can see him talking about these
particular cases you know these
particular victims that they have not
matched to a to a victim yet so this is
one that occurred in either 1971 or 1972
this happened in Miami Florida now he
says that he met this eighteen or
nineteen year old it was a transgender a
black woman this was in Miami um he said
that he didn't know her last name but
that her first name was Mary Ann or Mary
Ann like two words he wasn't really sure
said she was about five foot six five
foot seven about 140 pounds he said he
met her at a bar called the pool or the
pool palace which was near 17th Avenue
in Miami now he this was one where like
I said because he had like a several-day
relationship with some of these victims
so he met her at a bar
he went home apparently like a couple
days later he saw her at the bar again
and this time the bar was in Overton and
then he said he would give her a ride
home he says that she lived with a bunch
of other
roommates and it was somewhere an
apartment between Brownsville and
Liberty City he goes back to the
apartment where she lived as all these
roommates one of them said they needed
some shaving cream and somebody needs to
go out and buy some so they go back to
Samuel littles car which at the time was
a gold four-door pontiac lemans and he
took Mary Ann this victim he drove north
on highway 27 and ended up killing her
in a driveway that was near a sugarcane
field and he drove down highway 27 into
the Everglades turned down a dirt road
that led into either a river or a swamp
he wasn't really sure dragged her body
200 yards into the water and left the
body there he does not think the body
was ever found so this is one that he
confessed to that they have not found
the body as if yet like I said this is
in the Everglades so if anybody knows
anything about that FBI is like
interested in alligators actually [ __ ]
possibly like I said some of these as I
said like he's confessed to like 93 93
murders which if it was Henry Lee Lucas
or somebody like that
I would like doubt it but they have
matched him with so many unsolved crimes
he knew all these details he knew
exactly like how old a woman was about
how much she weighed what she was
wearing when she disappeared what city
it was what car he was driving he knew
all this stuff so they've been able to
match him with about like between 50 and
60 unsolved murders and the FBI have
come forward and stated it's like look
we're keeping a lot of like details like
close to they're fast and stuff but we
don't have any reason to doubt do any of
the other confessions that he has made
why would he make it up we don't even
live anywhere near the Everglades oh we
are in Florida when I was working when I
was taking care of dr. Matt's barn whose
doctor Matt's a [ __ ] rich [ __ ]
doctor religious Jews lives a couple of
miles yeah not even
box really up here and he has a barn
full of horses and a chicken coop and
fitting head-turner ghosts turned goats
and turkeys and all kinds of [ __ ] and my
he and his wife out of town I was taking
care of his [ __ ] farm and Turkey died
white was gone I grabbed that turkey and
just [ __ ] threw it out back behind
his property I came back six hours later
that [ __ ] turkey was gone
well Turkey is delicious animal everyone
in the animal kingdom knows that the
entire animal kingdom even in the
basically we're we're in the suburbs now
it was the suburbs really back then but
close I guess it you leave anything dead
out in Florida it's [ __ ] gone Florida
is a [ __ ] body disposal machine I
noticed the other day you know what's
interesting I noticed the other day like
I you know like I said I walked up and
down the seminal Cabot Trail like every
morning and for a while that was like a
body of a possum I think it was and um
you know so that was the possum body it
stunk for like a day or two I remember
this morning I went out walking and I
was like I wonder how much of that
possum body is left there's any bones
totally gone totally gone no bones have
nothing a human body I think would be
gone in about four days it probably
would be yeah that possum was gone in
two or three days yeah it's it smelled
really bad like the first day or two and
like I saw it like with the [ __ ] [ __ ]
and everything but then like today when
I went out there nothing a human body in
the water the fish the [ __ ] snapping
turtles alligator gar you know I mean
that would be gone just in a couple of
days yeah everything get that yeah we
have some I gave our roster it would be
gone by the time it was sucking rotten
there are so many creatures don't like
Australia yeah just so many creatures
that like feed on
things yeah yeah so the second case the
FBI is looking into this happened in
Little Rock Arkansas sometime between
1992 and 1994 now Samuel says that he
encountered a black female in a
transient area of Little Rock Arkansas
between 1992 and 94 he couldn't quite
remember he said when he met her it was
very cold and maybe snowing he said the
woman was about 24 years old about 5
foot 5 to 5 foot 7 she was about 200
pounds now he said that he stayed with
her off and on for about three days him
and the woman reportedly shoplifted some
various places
he says around this time that he was
arrested for shoplifting from a Kroger
grocery store
now the FBI checked this and indeed he
was arrested for shoplifting from a
Kroger by the North Little Rock Police
Department on April 20th 1994 so it was
sometime around then hmm so like I said
his memory is actually quite good yeah
because he did remember getting arrested
forever the [ __ ] month yeah like
being arrested for that and they did
check the records and he did get
arrested for that kind of [ __ ]
so the weird thing about it though he
gets arrested for shoplifting but he got
released because the Kroger grocery
store didn't like that his car had been
left in the parking lot and they wanted
him let out so he could move it or they
they wanted it moved they didn't like
want it hanging out there so he was like
only in the jail for like three hours
and then they released him and he goes
back to the car and apparently the woman
who hadn't killed yet was sleeping in
the back of his car which was the 1978
yellow Cadillac Eldorado could have been
a Dodge but he thought it was an
Eldorado it was on the grocery stores
property and they wanted it off so he
says that he goes back to the car she's
still sleeping inside he says that he
took this woman to meet her ex-boyfriend
who was called bear that wasn't his name
yeah he remembers a memory a lot of [ __ ]
yeah um so he says he took her to visit
bear and then took her to her house and
then he went away and then the next day
he came back and she needed a ride
toward either Benton or Bentonville
Arkansas so he gave her a ride and then
while he was giving her a ride there
outside of Little Rock and he decides
he's gonna strangle her hmm
so kill this [ __ ] yeah so he says thank
you that he went on the side of the road
that he strangled her wonder if he tells
him look baby they had a pool over I got
it I got that weird thing that he said
was that and I'm sure he's doing this
just to like justify his own actions but
he said Oh a lot of these women they
have a death wish
that's what he said yeah they wanted
that it's like yes so it's like I start
doing it and they're just like yeah do
it right and I'm like I find that Ryan I
find that hard to believe but he's
trying to endear himself to the [ __ ]
the Audis yeah he's trying to like make
it seem like oh well I just did what
they wanted wasn't a crime or anything
they wanted it or you know their life
was so miserable that I was doing them a
favor I that was mercy right I I kind of
feel like that's what he was doing like
that in a super overt way but that I
kind of got that impression so he
strangles this woman um he says that he
put her body on a pile of branches and
old corn stalks which was near a
cornfield
he thought her name might have been Ruth
and that her mother lived in North
Little Rock so that's another one that
the FBI are looking to match to a murder
there was another one that happened in
Covington or Covington Kentucky
Kentuckians can tell me head of
protection Covington that's what I
thought
in 1984 he says it was 1984 probably
summer he's
he was driving his Lincoln Continental
Mark three he was driving from Lorraine
Ohio to Cincinnati while he was enroute
he met a 25 year old white female
outside a strip club this was the woman
that I was talking about earlier that he
that he said approached him he was
parked behind a strip club and he said
like the trunk of his car was open and
he said this woman approached him and
wanted a ride to Miami now he described
this woman as being about five foot six
or five at seven I'm from Kentucky to
Miami yeah she wanted a ride that's
[ __ ] a long long way well it is yeah
all right but you know maybe she would
maybe she had family down there
you don't know maybe she was maybe he
just said he'd take her part of the way
that's a [ __ ] long way yeah sure but
yeah so yeah this is a white woman five
foot six five and seven 130 to 170
pounds he wasn't quite sure he said she
had real short blonde hair he said not
kind of like a bob but like just a
little bit under her ears said she had
blue eyes said she was kind of like a
hippie like looked kind of like a hippie
um like I said she asked him for a ride
to Miami and said that her mother lived
there so he said that he took this woman
south on Interstate 75 they got to
Cincinnati they hung out downtown on
Vine Street in Cincinnati then they just
kept on driving together go into
Northern Kentucky and then he says that
he drove to a hilly area not far from
interstate 75 drove up a small dirt road
to the top of a little Round Hill that's
a quote and he strangled her in the back
seat and left her body on the top of the
hill mmm so if anybody knows who that is
that it's another one that the FBI is
looking to match guess they never found
her they have not like I said most of
his confessions they have matched to
cold cases in whatever states there that
he said that he committed the crimes
because his memory is still very good
but you know when he knows enough
details that they can like match them
these are just the five that they're
still trying to like identify like who
the victim is or who's my balcony
it'll off of a dirt road beat that's
what he said yeah nobody found it hmm
yeah Northern Kentucky it's well it's a
big country and there's still like a lot
of rural area I mean I spend nothing in
that area I I feel like a lot of the
bodies of his victims have probably not
been bad some well we got coyotes got it
or something yeah and you have that
monitor as well like on animals and
stuff yeah now here's one that happened
in Las Vegas Nevada 1993 now he says in
1993 he was driving in 1978 yellow
Cadillac Eldorado to Los Angeles he
meets a black woman on Owen's Avenue or
Jackson Street in Las Vegas
he said she was thin she was very
dark-skinned she was about 40 years old
about five foot five said she was like I
said very skinny only 110 220 pounds um
he said that he thought that her hair
was probably short but that she wore a
wig that had like a long hair and that
was what he depicted in the drawing
because it was one of the victims that
he drew um said that she had a son who
was between 19 and 23 years old he said
that he took her to a motel room and
strangled her to death then placed her
body in the trunk of his car drove to
the outskirts of Las Vegas pulled off a
remote road and rolled her body down a
slope he also drove a little bit further
and threw her clothes out um they think
that it is likely that this body was
never found because he said he went
outside of Las Vegas and it's all like
[ __ ] desert out there now the fifth
victim that the FBI are looking forward
to match up with one of Samuel those
confessions this happened in New Orleans
Louisiana in 1982 now he says it was
probably about some time in the fall of
1982 he says he met a black female in
New Orleans she was
between 30 and 40 years old about five
foot eight 5 foot nine inches tall about
160 pounds he described her as having
honey colored skin brown skin she was a
she was a black woman medium length
straight hair
he said she was wearing a really pretty
dress with buttons on the front he said
he met her in a club she was at a
birthday party with a bunch of her
friends and one of her two sisters now
he says that she went with him in her
car in his car which was a Lincoln
Continental Mark three at the time he
also said that she told him that she
lived with her mother who had some kind
of illness or was maybe an invalid you
know couldn't leave her bed or whatever
um he also said that this woman in
particular had given him keys to her
house I'm not really sure why that was
maybe he was staying there at the time
so he says that he drove her to the
little woods exit off Interstate 10
then he turned down a dirt road along a
canal that was being dredged they both
got out of his car then he says he
pulled her toward the canal and then
strangled her to death and left the body
there then he said afterward that he
went back to the motel where he was
staying in Pascagoula Mississippi so
this is another confession that they
have as yet not matched to a cold case
murder but they are still trying to so
they're putting all this information out
like I said they put out like if you go
to the FBI's website they have like all
of the drawings that he's done one or
two of them have been matched to actual
people that you know they did look
enough like the person that you know
their relatives were able to identify
them but they're still trying to like
identify some other ones that they're
like not sure about here enough paper
yeah she's over there
yes it's cat control so what a piece of
paper start tearing it up and that's got
notes on it I didn't know that sir
it does but it's alright like you know
what I mean she she likes to eat paper
for whatever reason hi sweetie
yeah what do you new
the tiger King and I'm the [ __ ] kitty
kick the pokey game booty kick look you
can see don't you know that you are a
Pookie star oh yeah I told you in the
sidetrack show we singsong stir like my
favorite one just sing to her I don't
know if you know this you know that song
that's called who the [ __ ] did it
originally I know a lot of people have
covered it it's just called spooky yeah
let's boogie rise of Pookie so I always
kind of sing it I always kind of saying
to her psyche love's kind of crazy with
a Pookie of it okay okay okay we gotta
get back so that people are messed up
yes yeah so as I was saying like I said
I'm like I'm like grabbing this [ __ ] up
but these are the five particular cases
that the FBI is like worried about right
now they've been like updating the site
like the last update that I saw was
February and March of 2019
where they had actually like matched a
bunch of his confessions because if you
look at like some of the YouTube videos
I think he confessed to I think there
was like 14 of them on there that he
confessed to and they've like
subsequently been able to match those
two actual cases um they are still
trying to decide it's like should we
actually charge him with those because
we had to like x-ray him to other states
and it's like a big deal he's already
got a life sentence he's not getting out
so I can understand how relatives of the
victims might want closure and stuff but
I do feel like at this point it might be
a waste of time and money he'd be dead
in a few years yeah because you take a
decade almost 80 at this point and he's
in very very poor health so I don't know
like I think probably I mean sadly the
best she can hope for is that he
confesses to the crime you know he
probably did it the parents of all these
victims are probably dead most of them I
would think I mean so like so many of
them were so long ago like stop
attacking the camera and you can see it
like look at her little button
she's getting ready to leave so we'll be
yeah but yeah so so I feel like I you
know I can see how if it was my mom or
my sister or something like that yes you
would want that you would want him like
um you know convicted of that particular
crime but I feel like at this point it
took so long for them to catch him and
he's so old and in such bad health and
this is kind of like some [ __ ]
original Nightstalker Joseph D'Angelo
[ __ ] it's like by the time they caught
him he's like so [ __ ] old it's like
what are you gonna do about it he's kind
of beyond the green he's gonna [ __ ]
[ __ ] he's gonna [ __ ] die before any
of this [ __ ] I'm good I'm in prison and
he's just gonna talk [ __ ] and [ __ ]
play games for the next [ __ ] five six
seven years until these are the [ __ ]
worst and what are you gonna do yeah I
mean that's what I mean it's like it
sucks but at this stage I'd be like well
do we really want to like waste money on
this [ __ ]
yeah he's already in there yeah diangelo
for all that [ __ ] he's gonna do
something up tune of four or five years
well cuz he's gonna die yeah he's gonna
[ __ ] crook probably yeah it's like it
sucks because look how look how long he
got away with that [ __ ] look how long
Samuel little got away with this [ __ ] he
didn't get caught for all this [ __ ]
until 2012 he doesn't have to worry
about bills or anything this is his
retirement I guess he's gonna sit up
there and like he didn't even confess to
all these murders until 2008 teen that
was only two years ago and he's been
killing people since 1970 before I was
even born
yeah oh you know that reminds me of
D'Angelo the the [ __ ] the tattoo issue
somebody told me that we need to like
once his truck is his trial is yeah
somebody said we need to do another show
yeah like once the trial starts did he
really have a tattoo of a bull or a bull
dog on him you know what I don't even
remember at this point yeah we gotta go
back and check all that kind of [ __ ] cuz
that was before we knew who it was
yeah cuz we did a show before you got on
it that shows got sixty some sixty-three
thousand views on it I called that [ __ ]
because I remember having a lot of
predictions came true nostra tommix
Nostradamus [ __ ] spoke isn't that
[ __ ] weird like we did the show what
like what was it a year or two before he
got yeah a few weeks later [ __ ] ago
they caught his ass yeah and it's like
it's really we really weird to think
about because I always kind of feel like
all those crimes from like back in the
day that are have never been felt like
the zodiac and [ __ ] like that
I always feel like oh well they're never
gonna catch I wonder if that that [ __ ]
is probably dead one of that old [ __ ]
even knew anything about the interwebs
I wonder if he heard our show see I
always kind of what about that tail yeah
I'm dick [ __ ] like well did they
let the past the Internet in prison I
guess it depends on what prison no they
don't have it I don't think that's what
I thought I don't know I'm like but I
was wondering it he had it he had it at
that time he had to have but he probably
didn't even know what [ __ ] YouTube
was his boomer ass he's still like yo
tome I'm still on AOL yeah well that's
one thing that I kind of worry about
it's like I you know I I'm more
comfortable like covering cases that
where the perpetrators probably did yeah
we're not watching this yeah it's like
it kind of wears I'm gonna scare those
dudes though man but it is something
that you have to like be and honestly
because now I'm working on faceless
villain for which is gonna be unsolved
murders from 2000 2018 so most of those
perps are still alive so hopefully none
of them will kill me but if you guys
know if something bad happens so far
when it comes to serial killers the only
badass was D'Angelo but that was like he
was a [ __ ] 70s and 80s badass looking
that shit's not happening now
how bad is like breaking to people's
head with a [ __ ] mask on and like tie
everybody up yeah and you're a [ __ ]
put dishes on their back and you're a
[ __ ]
cop you're a serial killer and you're a
cop it's why I don't like cops yeah [ __ ]
because I do feel like but you know once
once the trial starts if it ever [ __ ]
does I think they're kind of like
waiting for him to shuffle off the
mortal coil let's say that they're just
kind of like waiting for him to die so
they don't have to like spend the money
to like go through the trial because
nobody wants to do he's going down which
you know that's that that would be the
best possible scenario for all involved
like I said I understand that if you had
a relative that was a victim like I
understand like mourning that closure
wanting that person to pay for what they
did but but that was an awful long time
ago yeah well yeah you are a relative
from that era probably gone like and as
long as like you saw the [ __ ] dude
die like he's in prison he's like this
little withered old man he's like this
pathetic nothing and he's you know I
mean it's like I I kind of feel like
that would be greater satisfaction
seeing him I would rather see them like
just become like old and withered and
unhealthy and insignificant and before
they died not lay claim to that [ __ ]
right because like if they got like the
electric chair or something like that
that might be seen as like more of a
badass death I guess I would rather see
you like get [ __ ] Alzheimer's or like
suffer [ __ ] suffer be like an old
person yeah like old person diseases I
don't look at it that way you want him
to kind of die in obscurity that's it
that's that's more like you don't want
them to be like super famous right and
like that's the thing in in some ways it
sucks that he got away with it for so
long but the fact that they caught him
and the same with Samuel little you know
the fact that they caught him when he
was already an old man I mean Sammy a
little didn't get caught so he was like
in his 70s yeah and in a way I think
that's a little more satisfying to me
it's like because I don't really need to
see them done
electric chair like with [ __ ] lethal
injection or whatever I get more
satisfaction seeing them becoming older
and more informaiton the funnier it is
to me mm-hmm
what else is left on this game I think I
think yeah well you know yeah I'm done
this [ __ ] is in custody he ain't gonna
wear and he's sold and he's not gonna
last much longer honestly because he is
in very very very bad health and not
that anyone feels bad unfortunately his
I don't the parents of his victims have
all passed by now probably although some
of the siblings and still be around
because I know that some of them are at
least you know who it was I don't think
this dude will ever be go to trial he'll
just die in obscurity imprisonment
didn't have long enough which maybe is
the best way for him because it's that's
what I mean that's like the weirdest
thing to me is that this guy
according to the FBI killed more people
than any other serial killer in America
it's weird
um you know there's other so like in
Colombia and Russia and stuff like that
they killed a lot more people but this
guy killed more people than anybody in
the US at least in the US and he's not
really super well-known like I said
doesn't have a murder PDF entry which is
very strange because everybody else cuz
that [ __ ] isn't exciting he's boring
maybe yeah I don't know what it is he's
just got him on a pig farm and hanging
them upside down in the buckets and [ __ ]
like that like yeah let that dude and
then they'll be that terrible it's like
we have to have like all these like
[ __ ] slow go it's gonna have to like
it hate this [ __ ] man card a
little bit like yeah you kill those
people but you're still insignificant
you didn't even make a mark yeah like
nobody even cares yeah no one even gives
a [ __ ] you're gonna I think it's because
the victims were prostitutes
yeah although you could say I mean Jack
the Ripper's victims are prostitutes it
looks at famouse is but that he was
violent but that's because he did like
some really
yeah this [ __ ] here had no character I
mean he just strangled upstream which I
mean that's bad but it wasn't like he
was like but he's he he wasn't like
making bowls out of these skulls like
that he is easily forgettable as a
nobody
that the victims are far more memorable
than the [ __ ] they are a perpetrator
so just another loser in a way maybe
that's good maybe that's good that we're
getting to that place where serial
killers are getting to the point where
they're not as interesting they're not
actions are because like I said that's
why I tried like you guys I tried really
hard in this case because like I said
there's not a lot of information about
this
despite his kill count if you want to
call it that but I did try really hard
to like find pictures of all the victims
you know rather yeah I have pictures of
him as well because that's what most of
the pictures are and it's sad because
you can find pictures of him really
easily pictures the victims much harder
and a lot of the victims don't have any
pictures of them yeah well it doesn't
matter because this [ __ ] here is this
[ __ ] here his [ __ ] [ __ ] mediocre
immortan joe would not approve they'd be
like yeah he's just mediocre but I'm
glad we did a show about it oh yeah like
I'm glad to make my show I'm glad
somebody like suggested this yeah
because I don't think and this is weird
because I'm into true crime and stuff
but it's like I had not heard of this
dude and then when I looked him - it was
like 93 people holy crap that's like way
up there yeah he's a strangler but he's
kind of like yeah he's kind of like on
the outskirts yeah there's not a lot of
like [ __ ] about him it's like really
weird it's it's a big [ __ ] jerk-off
that's what he does he's a jerk-off
artist yeah it does seem like that like
he was like impotent yeah I think he
even said that as he said ya couldn't
rock up where they were live yeah yeah
it like wait til they were dead
all right Jenny shut this [ __ ] down you
guys sucking like the show and you
enjoyed it go ahead and like share and
subscribe please do that yeah it really
does help a lot yeah and if you like the
show it's like we have we we've been
putting [ __ ] up
every [ __ ] day watch it well I mean
walking you through the Omega Man
apocalypse I mean sometimes we put up
two videos everyday because we put up
our daily show and then sometimes we put
up movie early so we would appreciate
your support and we will continue yeah I
mean honestly if all you do is like put
a little like button if you like share
with somebody who likes that [ __ ] that's
cool that's all you gotta do that's all
you can do now if you want to give us
money that's also awesome - you got our
patreon page drunk Jani well you know
we're a super Jenny okay fine I'll be
sober tomorrow so yeah that's the thing
about that's the thing about drunk it
wears off after an hour - right yeah and
and drunk people and sober people need
money in the same fashion we're gonna
see you guys tomorrow with the next
[ __ ] sidetracks we'd give you a daily
update we'll keep you up abreast yeah
we're recording this on Friday yeah so
you will give you a Saturday update keep
keep you [ __ ] in line keep you on top
of the situation well I know that
everybody's kind of bummed out about
like having to like [ __ ] self isolate
in their apartments like I said I like
that [ __ ] because I don't like people so
I'm just like woohoo yeah it's quiet for
a change but you know what I mean it's
like I don't mind it it doesn't bother
me but I understand that like oh yeah
something like that with like [ __ ]
three roommates none of these [ __ ]
have any money they're in their [ __ ]
fartin and living off a damn living off
a road and [ __ ] that was I ramen and
[ __ ] car certainly my experience is
not other people's experience I'm not
having like a hugely shaken ahead it's
well okay like it's a plan ahead though
it's a little bit of look I'm broke -
okay so I feel you I'm broke - uh you
know but up honestly like I'm
a social anyway so it's kind of like I'm
kind of fine with just being in my
office all day and not talking to anyone
that's cool with me I like quiet um
other than like our dryer being broke
that's pretty much our biggest
inconvenience yeah and not being able to
like go I dance and I hate that but in
order to survive the apocalypse my
suggestion and just get out you if I can
get out of pack of ramen put some coffee
creamer in it and it's app and a pack of
[ __ ] Vienna sausages it's like your
red chili flakes no you [ __ ] you'll
make it through got have protein somehow
and don't try to cook potted meat if you
try to cook potted meat and [ __ ]
disintegrates you're just gonna have
[ __ ] clear grease and it's like a
little flecks of meat in it I tried all
that low oh man [ __ ] die I got
serious for real the only good thing
like I love ramen the only good thing to
put a ramen boiled eggs vegetables and
vegetable spam no no no and they will
put spam I know but who had a nose had
it [ __ ] cook that's poor people
cooking and you're supposed to be you're
supposed to be a export person I used to
lard I'm still a poor for a syllable I
stole like well I mean I would eat it if
I was starving to death
but I gave her a bacon spam I fried that
[ __ ] and gave it to her she's like oh
that's pretty good
no I said it was okay I said it's it's
all right I'm done talking so much no
but no it was good it was it was fine
but you know what I mean it's like if
you're gonna like make I love ramen
noodles ramen noodles are good with
soft-boiled eggs in them okay you bust
the soft-boiled egg open and you get the
yolk that's what I give you soup yeah
that's good yeah it's good like that
yeah don't you shut it down Jenny
okay shows you I can shut down that I
have your permission okay so all right
Tom says that I can shut down episode
one about serial killers save me a
little okay yeah
okay so he already said like like share
subscribe all that [ __ ] yeah if you if
you want to give us money you don't have
to I know it's like it's rough out there
for everybody it's probably there for me
it's rough out there for everybody but
you know if you can if you want to like
support the show financially you can do
that go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
or you can go to our blog 13:05 podcast
don't wordpress.com and there's a link
in the sidebar
it's a little button and you can go to a
PayPal account which goes right to yours
charlie if you would like to give a
one-time donation to the show it would
be much appreciated or if you like to
send us movies or anything like that you
can like message me and I'll give you
our home address if you want to send us
movies
we always like movies because we like to
watch it that'll do it for episode 191
hope you guys have enjoyed this rambling
discussion as always we will see you
next time
[Music]
you
[Music]